[Musique]
Em Caron, bonsoir. Bonjour.
Bonsoir SVW.
Euh nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Merci.
Nous sommes en direct. On vous reçoit
dans le cadre de votre livre Utopia 21
et de trois autres sujets. Est-ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter succintement
?
Succintement ? Oui, je suis un être
humain
qui a 47 ans et puis français d'après en
tout cas notre registre des nationalités
et
j'ai travaillé 20 ans comme journaliste
avant de commencer à écrire des livres,
ce que je fais maintenant depuis
quelques années. Et par ailleurs, je
crois qu'on peut dire que je suis assez
engagé dans la défense des du vivant en
général et des animaux en particulier.
journaliste qui faisait quoi ? Comment
va l'état de la presse ? Votre avis sur
la presse ?
Quelle question ? La presse,
je sais pas, disons que je la reconnais
pas vraiment par rapport à à celle que
je
dans laquelle j'ai baigné quand j'ai
commencé ce métier il y a 25 ans. En
plus, j'étais journaliste télé, alors
tout a changé terriblement.
Euh
je risque de dire des banalités hein, de
constater que tous les grands médias
sont détenus par des grands groupes
financiers qui ont forcément une
influence sur la ligne éditoriale de ces
grands médias
que donc il faut se méfier sur la
lecture des événements qui nous y est
donné. On a par ailleurs des médias
juste à côté qui essayent de subsister,
qui font un travail formidable euh qui
sont des médias euh qui eux justement
essaie d'être indépendants et euh bah
parmi lesquels médias partent bien
évidemment, mais on pourra en citer
d'autres arrêt sur image ou alors des
des des boîtes de prod aussi qui font
des choses bien. Il y a des niches aussi
hein, par exemple euh cache
investigation. Voilà, on a des émissions
comme ça même sur le service public qui
qui sont vraiment d'intérêt public. Mais
c'est compliqué, c'est compliqué. Il y a
quand même une voix unique dominante qui
se fait entendre dans l'ensemble des
médias français et on le voit très bien
l'occasion des des gilets jaunes. Donc
je pense en plus que cette unicité est
en train de se renforcer depuis quelques
années.
Les gilets jaunes, ils ont été traités
comment ? Ça a été un traitement sain de
l'information
neutre qui présentait les faits qui ne
présentait uniquement que les faits.
Bah vous venez de démontrer que c'est
marrant comment on peut être journaliste
et
afficher une neutralité mais qui n'est
que d'affichage puisque votre question
contient déjà une réponse.
Si vous me la posez avec ces mots-là,
c'est que non.
Les gilets jaunes n'ont pas été
présentés de manière très objective.
Il y a une certaine image d'eux qui a
été véhiculée. Il y a eu bien évidemment
comme dans tout mouvement un peu
improvisé, mouvement social improvisé,
pas vraiment maîtrisé avec des énergies
non pas contraires mais en tout cas
différentes qui s'agrègent et des
motivations parfois différentes qui
s'agrègent. Il y a eu des dérives, des
débordements, mais on est quand même
bien obligé de constater que les médias
ont surtout insisté sur ces dérives ou
ces débordements qui d'après ce que moi
j'ai pu en voir puisque je pas fait
moi-même de reportage dessus. Donc je me
contente d'avoir un avis sur ce que j'ai
vu euh par les médias. Donc c'est c'est
pas forcément une analyse extrêmement
approfondie. En tout cas, j'ai
l'impression que ces débordements à
chaque fois étaient le fait de quelques
individus mais était pas représentatif
d'un mouvement. Et surtout on a pu
constater quand même que les médias
focalisaient à chaque fois sur ces
quelques incidents pour laisser croire
qu'ils étaient représentatifs de des
valeurs portées par le mouvement alors
qu'il n'en était rien. C'est-à-dire que
je crois que c'est un mouvement
extrêmement important qui dit des choses
très fortes sur l'état social de notre
pays avec des gens qui descendent dans
la rue parce que vraiment ils sont
désespérés. Désespérés au sens
étymologique. Ils n'ont plus d'espoir.
C'est qu'est-ce que je peux faire moi
aujourd'hui et demain ? Qu'est-ce qui va
se passer pour moi ? Il me manque 200
300 € pour finir le mois parce que j'ai
dû payer j'ai dû payer le FU, j'ai dû
payer l'électricité, j'ai dû payer la
cantine de mes enfants
et
c'est des gens qui disent quelque chose
de très important et les médias c'est
vrai ont vachement axé sur la question
des violences qui qui est une qui
d'ailleurs question qui n'est pas tout à
fait éclairc dans un certain nombre de
cas. Qui a été auteur de ces violences ?
Euh est-ce que c'était vraiment des
gilets jaunes ?
quel genre de gilet des jaunes et cetera
et cetera.
Et surtout on voit qu'en face la
question des violences policières a mis
beaucoup de temps à à atterrir dans dans
le débat public. C'estàd que c'est on
commence enfin à en parler un petit peu
et heureusement et là c'est intéressant,
on a vu un travail citoyen. Ça c'est
Vous me posez une question il y a
quelques instants sur l'état du
journalisme aujourd'hui. C'est
intéressant quand il y a le journalisme
citoyen qui arrive et qui permet de
faire avancer certains sujets. Je pense
au travail de David Dufren notamment,
mais qui lui-même a repris le travail de
de beaucoup de de de de gens, de
citoyens qui étaient dans la rue, des
gilets jaunes, pas des gilets jaunes, en
tout cas des gens qui filmaient ce qui
se passait et qui tout à coup ont permis
de voir la répression policière, une
répression complètement inédite dans ce
pays, en tout cas dans l'époque moderne
sur les 30 dernières années avec un
sentiment d'impunité incroyable appuyé
par le gouvernement qui a vraiment
vraiment donné tous les gages pour que
pour que les autres en face se sent
libre de faire ce qu'ils voulaient enfin
en face que le tout ce que les policiers
puissent faire ce qu' ce qu' ce qu'ils
avaient envie de faire. Euh
et on a quand même pour répondre à votre
question initiale le sentiment quand on
écoute une fois plus j'aime bien cette
petite musique dominante l'idée on a
quand même le sentiment que que que les
médias mainstream ont voulu nous donner
l'image vraiment de de de de
voyou de voyou en train de vouloir
déstabiliser gratuitement quasiment le
pays. Euh donc avec des enfin avec des
des des
penseurs médiatiques aussi qui en ont
rajouté une couche là-dessus. Enfin
penseur médiatique
patenté.
Patenté.
Oui. Non, je vais pas citer le nom.
Enfin, on les reconnaîtra.
Quand on voit euh Nicolas Dupignan se
clasher sur c'est la 5
H
avec la journaliste, comment elle
s'appelle ? Ellisabeth Lemoine.
Exactement. Et
si je peux vous filer un coup de main,
n'hésitez pas.
Ouais. On regarde pas la télé en fait.
Donc euh
il y a juste
vous faites de la télé un peu quand
même.
Ouais. On fait un peu de la radio pirate
mais avec des images.
Ouais. C'est de la télé.
Ouais.
C'est juste un autre canal de diffusion
que que le canal classique.
Ouais. Ouais.
C'était ça la nouvelle télé.
Peut-être.
C'est peut-être vous qui êtes en train
de l'inventer en fait.
Ouais. avec euh Marc Hullman qui nous a
beaucoup aidé avant euh qu'il claque. On
lui on lui dédie un peu euh notre
chaîne. Je sais pas si vous connaissez
Marc Hulman.
Euh donc Nicolas Duponignon qui se
clashe en disant voilà euh vous les
laquers du pouvoir, je résume
trivialement trivialement les laquers du
pouvoir on sait bien que pour qui vous
roulez. Hm.
Euh
une idée là-dessus, une pensée, une
analyse, une critique. C'est légitime,
c'est pas légitime, c'est une stratégie
à la Trump, c'est une stratégie,
c'est c'est épuisant, c'est tout est
gênant dans cette séquence. Tout est
gênant.
Ce qui est gênant, c'est le ton employé
par du poignant qui est quand même un
type du système
qui a fait quand même toute sa carrière
dans un
comment dirais-je dans un écosystème
politique extrêmement conservateur qui
en a bien profité et qui maintenant
prend son indépendance
effectivement en s'appuyant sur des
mécanismes qu'on a vu ailleurs.
J'ai pas envie d'utiluer le mot
populisme parce que il est égalodé, on
sait même plus trop vraiment ce qu'il
veut dire.
Magogue,
c'est plus compliqué que ça en fait. Moi
je crois que l'un des gros soucis
aujourd'hui c'est on a vraiment
un débat politique
idéologique et complètement caricatural
avec oui alors d'un côté on aurait les
populistes de l'autre côté on aurait les
démagogues, on aurait les humanistes,
les pas humanistes, on aurait les
racistes, les pas racistes. Je pense que
tout est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
et que chacun est sommet de se ranger
dans une catégorie et de dire vous
l'êtes vous êtes ça alors oui ou non. Il
doit assumer un truc au contraire de pas
du tout.
Et je pense que cette obligation de
catégorisation est en train de nuire
complètement au débat et la qualité de
la pensée
et de la réflexion. Donc démagogue non
si lorsque Dupon Aignant dit que les
médias aujourd'hui sont dominés par une
certaine pensée,
on peut pas lui donner tort. Je viens
moi-même de le dire il y a quelques il y
a quelques minutes. Après, il y a une
manière de le dire. Dire de de gens qui
vous invitent sur la plate, vous êtes
les laqués du je sais pas si c'est le
mot qu'il a employé. C'est pas ça mais
ça ressemblait
mais enfin le le souvenir que j'en ai,
je l'ai pas j'ai pas pris cette séquence
par cœur non plus mais c'est quelque
chose une espèce de virulence de ce que
je n'aime pas c'est la forme la manière
de dire les choses. Je pense qu'on doit
essayer de conserver toujours une forme
d'élégance
et de respect de l'autre même lorsqu'on
lui reproche quelque chose ou qu'on veut
entamer un débat contradictoire assez
fort. et Yach du poignant un mépris
total à ce moment-là en tout cas dans le
souvenir que j'ai de cette cette
séquence de gens qui l'invitent et ces
gens qui invitent du poignant sont sans
doute pas d'accord avec lui mais c'est
vrai il faut reconnaître qu'il l'invite
quand même donc déjà c'est c'est une
politesse qu'on doit rendre en face il
peut en revanche exprimer l'idée que son
interlocuteur je crois qu'il s'adressa à
Patrick Cohen selon lui défend des
points de vue qui sont des points de vu
dominants et qui sont des points de vue
macronistes il peut très bien le dire
calmement gentiment en disant regardez
vous venez de dire ceci Vous venez de
dire cela. Moi j'ai déjà eu Patrick
Cohen en face de moi plusieurs fois et
on est en désaccord sur un symptôme de
sujet. Ça s'est toujours très bien
passé. J'ai et je lui ai toujours dit
que j'étais pas d'accord ou que sur sur
tel point il se trompait complètement
selon moi parce qu'il était dans une
vision complètement arriérée des choses
et cetera. Donc ce qui est dommage,
c'est que du poignet met le doigt sur un
truc intéressant car je crois en effet
que lorsqu'on voit comment fonctionne le
service public aujourd'hui, on peut
s'interroger sur l'indépendance de
service public à l'égard du pouvoir,
notamment parce que tous les directeurs
sont nommés euh pas directement ou
indirectement, c'est indirect
maintenant, mais enfin on sait très bien
les circuits, comment ça fonctionne sont
nommés par avec l'aval en tout cas du
gouvernement donc la directrice de
France Télévision mais on peut aller
voir la même chose à Radio France et
cetera tout Ça, ce sont des ce sont des
gens qui tournent, ce sont des amis
d'amis qui étaient d'abord dans des
cabinets ou ou dans des dans des grandes
entreprises qui dépendent de l'État.
Enfin, c'est son et puis ensuite, il
nomme des gens qui sont des gens de
confiance, politiquement de confiance.
Donc, il serait aujourd'hui complètement
euh faux d'affirmer que les France Télé,
en tout cas les médias nationaux sont
indépendants du pouvoir en place. Ça
n'est pas vrai. Ça n'est pas vrai.
Donc on peut très bien le dire
calmement, gentiment en rappelant les
les circonstances de nomination d'un tel
ou un tel sans pour autant devenir
méprisant. Voilà
le monde Xavier Niel qui dit "Quand les
journalistes m'ennuient,
je prends des parts dans le canard et il
m'ennuie moins et m'ennuie plus."
Bah au moins c'est à la méie de la
franchise.
Je crois que c'est un vieux procédé.
Les chaînes infos au départ, pourquoi
elles ont existé ?
Je crois que la première c'était LCI
pour TF1. Ensuite dans l'ordre, je crois
qu'il y a eu Ité pour Canal.
Ensuite BFM qui qui appartient aussi au
groupe
RMC.
Maintenant, il y a l'IB aussi, mais ça
c'est c'est différent. Enfin, c'est le
groupe Drahi. Au départ, c'est des
chaînes infos, c'est des instruments de
pouvoir. L'idée, c'est ça. L'idée, c'est
on va faire venir des hommes politiques
sur notre plateau. On aura une chaîne
sur laquelle on pourra faire venir en
permanence des hommes politiques ou des
influenceurs politiques et puis on
pourra discuter avec eux, on pourra
prendre un café juste avant l'émission
et cetera et cetera. Euh, il y a
toujours une volonté, enfin voilà,
d'assaut et cetera. Il y a il y a cette
volonté en effet de gens de pouvoir
d'argent d'investir dans de la presse
pour ensuite travailler les réseaux
d'influence.
Kretinski par exemple, c'est ce qu'il
fait
avec Marianne,
avec Marianne et plein d'autres
journaux, plein d'autres médias
aujourd'hui. Donc là, on est sur un
homme d'affaires étranger qui veut
investir dans les médias aujourd'hui.
C'est pas par amour de la presse.
Le monde aussi, c'est c'est bien
évidemment pour favoriser ses affaires.
On va on va euh
changer de sujet mais en fait c'est
connecté. On va parler d'Utopia 21.
Votre bouquin, ça parle de quoi votre
bouquin ? Vous
l'avez pas lu ?
Si, on l'a lu. Mais comment vous le
décriviez ? Comment décriveriez-vous
votre livre ?
Comment je décrirai ce livre ? Bah,
en fait, j'ai toujours été euh
depuis que je suis ados, j'ai toujours
été passionné, fasciné par le mot
utopie.
Ce livre est parti de là.
Euh et en j'avais été interpellé par le
titre d'un livre de René Dumont
au titre des années 70 qui avait écrit
un livre qui s'appelait l'utopie ou la
mort. René Dumont premier candidat
écologiste à l'élection présidentielle
en 1974.
Je trouve ce titre formidable l'utopie
ou la mort et c'est sont deux mots enfin
une expression l'utopie ou la mort qui
m'est resté vraiment ancré dans le
cerveau toute ma vie depuis que je suis
ados. qui m'a guidé d'ailleurs dans
beaucoup de mes choix
et j'avais envie de de travailler sur ce
mot d'utopie après
un livre qui s'appelait antispéciste qui
lui était consacré
au droits des animaux, au droits du
vivant, à l'écologie et j'avais envie
sur mon pour mon prochain livre de
travailler autour de cette question
d'utopie parce qu'il me semblait qu'on
était entré dans une ère qui se refusait
de rêver.
Euh le rêve est empêché aujourd'hui. Il
est empêché par les dirigeants
politiques. Il est empêché par la quasi
majorité des gens que vous vous croisez
dans votre vie, dans votre vie
professionnelle.
Et on en a eu l'illustration. C'est
drôle parce que lorsque j'écrivais le
livre euh donc j'avais déjà moi cette
thématique euh je me suis retrouvé
pendant la campagne présidentielle et à
ce moment-là ça a été le moment où Amon
a a remporté la primaire
et on a commencé attendre dans les
médias les mes fameux médias dominant
mais donc France Télé mais tous les
autres aussi ça peut être le Figaro ça
peut être Libération et cetera on s'est
mis à entendre des journalistes nous
expliquai qu'aujourd'hui en France deux
gauches s'opposaient une gauche réaliste
qui était incarné par Manuel Vals et une
gauche utopiste.
La gauche réaliste de Manuel Vals, c'est
celle qui fait des alliances en Espagne
avec
alors c'était pas encore le cas à
l'époque mais c'est celle qui disait "Ah
là les étrangers attention notre pays on
peut pas on peut pas." C'était celle qui
disait bah oui euh je sais pas enfin
vous connaissez le programme de de Val,
c'était un programme finalement très à
droite sur la finance. Il faisait ben
non on peut pas augmenter les on peut
pas augmenter les salaires, on peut pas
ceci. Oui, il faut donner plus aux
entreprises. Enfin bon et puis la gauche
utopiste, c'est celle qui réfléchissait
au revenus au revenus minimum. C'est
celle qui réfléchissait à la à la
diminution du temps de travail. C'est
celle qui réfléchissait à l'écologie,
qui disait comment on peut intégrer
vraiment l'écologie pour en faire
quelque chose euh un vecteur important
de la réflexion politique. Donc et les
médium commencé à nous expliquer donc la
gauche utopiste c'était Benoît Amon
parce que lui réfléchissait à ces thèm
là
et d'autres mettaient aussi Mélenchon
là-dedans. Donc des gens qui disaient
par exemple faut limiter les revenus, il
faut augmenter les impôts des plus
riches. Voilà, ça c'est des utopistes
pour les médias mainstream. Et c'est
très drôle parce qu'en réalité ça
corroborit tout à fait ce que moi
j'essayé d'expliquer dans ce livre.
L'utopie est empêchée. Le rêve mais par
utopie par rêve c'est quoi ? C'est
simplement volonté d'un mieux d'un
changement. D'imaginer un autre système
de société qui aille à contre-courant de
celui dans lequel on évolue aujourd'hui.
Donc on est entouré d'empêcheur de
rêver,
d'empêcheur d'imaginer.
Et euh je pense que c'est tout le
contraire du progrès humain qui
au contraire a toujours été
motivé uniquement par des rêveurs.
C'est-à-dire que il y a des gens à jour
qui dont la voix s'est élevée dans la
société pour dire "Mais voyez, on vit
avec ça mais ça ça va pas du tout du
tout." Alors ça peut être plein de
choses dans le dans le Utopiage. Je
prends plein d'exemples. Ça peut être
les premières premières femmes qui se
sont dit "Mais pourquoi j'ai pas le
droit de vote ?"
qui ont dit "Pourquoi j'ai pas le droit
de travailler ?" Les premières personnes
qui se sont je sais pas quelqu'un comme
Schelcher en France qui s'est battu pour
l'abolition de l'esclavage, c'est c'est
c'est Simon Veille qui se bat pour pour
l'IVG.
tous les gens pour les premiers
Harv Milk pour pour les droits des
homosexuels aux États-Unis, tous ces
gens qui à un moment
porté un combat qui semblait quasi perdu
d'avance parce qu'il allait tellement à
contre-courant des habitudes
idéologiques de la société dans laquelle
il s'exprimait,
euh tous ces gens étaient des rêveurs,
des utopistes à qui on a dit "Mais
laisse tomber, tu arriveras jamais,
c'est comme ça, c'est comme ça."
Bon et ça ça me ça me fascine tous ces
gens qui ont été capables souvent au nom
de beaucoup de sacrifices euh qui ont
été capable de faire fi de tous ces
empêcheurs de rêver. Et aujourd'hui, je
crois qu'on est arrivé à un stade à une
société où euh de toutes parts, on nous
explique qu'il ne faut surtout plus
rêver. Les gilets jaunes, c'est ça hein.
On en revient à nos discussions d' 15
minutes. Il y a des tas de gens qui
tombent de partout, des gens qu'on
entend dans les médias qui s'prit pour
expliquer mais non, on peut pas.
Qu'est-ce qu'il réclame ? Ils veulent
quoi ces gens ? Ils veulent quoi des des
référums, des référendums
d'initiative citoyennes ? Mais pourquoi
faire ? Mais ils s'en fous et cetera et
cetera. Rien ne va. Rien va. Donc moi,
je réfléchissais à cette question de
l'utopie et puis je me suis dit
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui
sur l'utopie ?
et et en faisant mes recherches, en
lisant beaucoup de livres, ce sont comme
ça que je travaille, je lis beaucoup sur
le thème sur lequel je vais écrire, je
suis retombé sur le livre Utopia de
Thomas Mor
500 ans.
Ouais. Qui ce effectivement avait été
publié en 1516 et c'est Thomas Mort qui
a inventé le mot utopie. Euh et à
l'époque où je j'écrivais ce livre, on
était en 2016 au moment où j'ai commencé
à réfléchir à ce livre. Et donc je c'est
fou quoi, il y a 500 ans pile mais année
à une année près, il y a 500 ans tout
pile le mot Utopie a été inventé. C'est
dingue. Qu'est-ce qu'il en reste
aujourd'hui ? On en est où ? Et euh lui
de Thomas Mor c'était quoi ? C'était
ça partait d'une expérience vécue réelle
où il racontait que lui Thomas Mor avait
était en dans ce qui est aujourd'gique.
Il était en Flandre en mission en
Flandre et puis qu'il avait été
rencontré un ami et puis cet ami lui
avait présenté un voyageur un navigateur
et et c'est là qu'on rentrait dans
l'imaginaire dans le réciit parce que
dans la vie de Thomas Mor il se trouve
qu'il était vraiment allé en Flandre en
mission à cette période là de sa vie. il
avait vraiment été chez l'ami cite dans
le livre, sauf qu'il n'avait jamais
rencontré bien évidemment le le
navigateur en question puisque c'était
un personnage inventé et que ce
navigateur revenait d'une île appelé
Utopia qui était une île où les gens
étaient parfaitement heureux parce que
cette île était régie par un
gouvernement idéal et le livre et le
récit de ce qui se passe sur cette île.
C'est également dans ce livre une il y a
aussi la première partie du livre est
une critique du régime euh qui est alors
en place en Angleterre à l'époque.
Thomas Mor est aussi un critique de son
époque tout en étant un homme politique
de son époque. Bref, et je me suis dit
c'est drôle, on a qu'à imaginer que euh
il faudrait réécrire en fait faire un un
séquel, on dirait aujourd'hui à à ce
livre vieux de 500 ans. Qu'est-ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui sur Utopia 500 ans
après sa découverte ? Et j'ai donc
décidé de réécrire le Thomas Mort de
l'époque avec un livre qui comprend une
partie qui est une partie très critique
de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans
notre société. Puis une partie qui
décrit exactement, j'ai retrouvé dans
mon livre un descendant du navigateur
imaginaire évidemment qui avait
rencontré Thomas Mor et moi je rencontre
un de ses descendants qui m'ont raconte
lui aussi ce qui a évolué sur l'île
d'Utopie depuis 500 ans. Donc quel est
le gouvernement idéal ? toujours l'île
du du bonheur absolu pour tous, mais
comment ce bonheur est réalisé
aujourd'hui ? Et euh et il y a euh dans
ce livre Utopia 21 euh des propositions,
des des des idées concrètes à mettre en
place. Je voulais pas que ce soit un
livre simplement de critique.
On va y venir. 500 ans après le le
gouvernement idéal, le bonheur, c'est
quoi ?
C'est une excellente question. Je crois
que c'est
le gouvernement a pris quelle quelle
forme ? C'est une c'est un c'est une un
gouvernement basé sur la religion, c'est
basé sur
Non, sur l'île d'utopie, il y a pas de
religion. Enfin si, les gens peuvent une
religion s'ils veulent, mais la religion
prend enfin place extrêmement marginale
parce que comme je l'explique dans le
livre,
c'est une théocratie, c'est pas une
théocratie, c'est une dictature, c'est
pas une dictature
non, c'est une démocratie très très
démocratique, la plus démocratique
possible. Euh alors c'est il y a
beaucoup de choses à il y a beaucoup de
choses à imaginer.
Euh d'abord effectivement c'est un une
société dans laquelle la religion a
quasiment disparu parce que les gens se
sont rendus compte que tout était
extrêmement irrationnel dans les dans
les croyances religieuses par
définition.
Ça fait pourquoi la religion ?
La religion c'est
il y a plusieurs
fonctions.
Vous avez un ami imaginaire, vous croyez
à quelque chose ?
Moi euh est-ce que je crois en quelque
chose ?
Non. Non, je crois pas. Je crois pas en
Dieu. Je crois pas
je crois pas en l'au-delà. Je crois pas
en une
en un monde parallèle. Je crois pas qu'
reste quoi que ce soit
architecte. Non.
Alors, l'histoire du grand architecte,
c'est encore autre chose. Euh, une
espèce de dessin de la nature.
Alors là, pour ce fait vraiment partie,
moi je suis absolument passionné par ces
questions de mon dernier livre s'appelle
vivant et mais d'ailleurs, je me posais
déjà ces questions un peu dans
antispécie, c'est-à-dire que je
m'intéresse réellement à la question de
l'apparition de la vie et la question de
l'évolution de la vie. Ça c'est
quelque chose qui je pense que c'est
aujourd'hui mon questionnement
principal. C'est d'ailleurs ce qui a
beaucoup évolué dans ma vie depuis
depuis 20 ans parce que pendant des
années, j'étais c'est pour ça que j'ai
du mal aujourd'hui à redevenir
journaliste comme je je le je l'ai été
pendant longtemps. C'est qu'aujourd'hui
les questions qui m'intéressent le plus
c'est des questions qui n'ont plus grand
chose à voir avec mon métier de
journaliste. Si ce n'est que j'essaie
d'y appliquer des méthodes de
journaliste.
C'est vraiment la question du du
questions
auxquelles on ne peut pas répondre par
définition. C'est c'est comment et
pourquoi on est là ? Qu'est-ce qui fait
que la vie est apparue ? Quels sont les
mécanismes biologiques qui nous ont
permis d'évoluer jusqu'à ce que nous
sommes aujourd'hui et vers quoi la vie
va nous amener ? Vers quoi ces ces
mécanismes de vie vont vont nous amener
? Est-ce qu'il y a un un grand
architecte
de tout cela ? Euh non, je ne le crois
pas. Mais en même temps, c'est ça qui
est absolument passionnant et et et
vertigineux comme question, c'est
effectivement celle de la question des
origines. Je pense que la question la
l'une des questions les les plus
importantes qui soit pour chacun d'entre
nous, c'est la question des origines,
des débuts. C'est d'ailleurs ça c'est un
des choses que je raconte dans Utopia,
c'est que
la question qu'on doit tous se poser
tout le temps est celle du début sur
toute chose. Quand est-ce que ça a
commencé et pourquoi ça a commencé ?
C'est tout. Ce soit dans dans les
relations humaines, que ce soit dans
l'histoire, que ce soit vous prenez un
fait par exemple, un fait d'actualité,
un fait historique.
Chaque fois, vous êtes obligé de vous
demander pour le comprendre quel est son
début et vous rendez compte queon n'est
jamais d'accord sur le début de ce fait.
Ça c'est quelque chose qui me passionne
aussi parce que si on ne comprend pas
son début, on ne peut pas comprendre les
causes et les responsabilités. Or, je
pense que
pour moi le le souci principal
de l'humanité aujourd'hui en globalité,
mais aussi le souci de tout être humain,
c'est la question de la responsabilité.
C'est-à-dire c'est ce qui c'est une
question qui est complètement éludée
aujourd'hui qui est d'ailleurs
complètement relié à la question de
l'écologie parce que la question de
l'écologie c'est la question de la
responsabilité
que l'on pose à chacun d'entre nous et
qu'on essaie d'ériger en question de
société. Mais on s'éloigne. Mais j'adore
ça. Mais la question
temp on a il y a pas de
Non parce que là on peut parler
extrêmement longtemps de tout cela. Pour
revenir à la question de l'architecte,
c'est vrai que il y a quand même un
mystère
qui euh qui remonte à 13,67
milliards d'années en arrière qui est ce
mystère du bing bang, c'est-à-dire
comment on peut partir d'une petite
boule d'énergie de la tête d'une épingle
pour arriver à la création de l'univers
tel qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui
euh
avec
ces millions ces centaines de millions
d'étoiles.
de de système enfin de système solaire
de galaxie.
Donc c'est absolument passionnant. Alors
est-ce que vraiment tout ça est le fruit
du hasard ? Est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un
derrière qui régit tout cela ? J'en sais
rien. J'ai aucune j'ai aucune réponse à
ça.
Revenons à nos moutons. l'écologie,
ce qui se passe, la politique de Macron
en écologie de rugie, le grand débat
autour de ces questions là, c'est
de la branlette, c'est une façon
d'accaparer
le débat,
d'accaparer le
micro, l'image, de justifier son
salaire, de de justifier sa position, de
faire semblant de trouver des solutions.
L'écologie
c'est c'est l'adversaire idéologique de
Macron.
C'est c'est ça pas l'air ce que de de
penser Yannick Jadou. Il pense pas ça.
Il veut être l'incarnation de l'écologie
gouvernementale.
C'est autre chose. On parlait de Macron.
L'écologie pour moi, c'est aujourd'hui
le seul projet politique valable mais
c'est un projet politique
révolutionnaire.
Pour moi, il y a eu deux grandes
idéologies politiques qui sont
affrontées depuis 200 ans. Il y a eu le
socialisme
et un certain nombre de déclinaisons du
socialisme et puis a eu le capitalisme
ou le libérisme. Sachant que les choses
sont plus compliquées puisqu'on peut
avoir un capitaliste socialiste, un
capitalisme socialiste. Mais en gros,
alors on va dire plutôt le libéralisme
économique et le socialisme avec des tas
de déclinaisons. Le socialisme
aujourd'hui en tant que projet politique
est mort. Il est décédé avec la chute du
mur de Berlin en 89.
Euh donc aujourd'hui, on a un seul
projet politique dominant sur l'ensemble
de la planète, c'est le libéralisme
économique avec la forme qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui en France, le
néolibéralisme.
Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi ? Quoi ?
Pourquoi ? On a ça en en ligne de mire.
Pourquoi ?
Ouais. Pourquoi le c'est c'est le le le
alors là il faut il faut interviewer des
des des historiens de de de l'histoire
politique et de l'histoire des idées. Là
on en a pour au moins 2 heures. Bah
parce que c'est c'est la question des
rapports de force. Il est il est à
partir du moment où où
où la guerre euh
idéologique qui a dominé depuis des
années, c'est celle effectivement en
fait les on pouvait pas gagner.
C'est-à-dire quand je dis on,
c'est-à-dire les défenseurs d'une
certaine vision de la société du
partage, la société
de de l'empathie, la société en fait on
pourrait dire
une société issue du programme des jours
heureux, c'est-à-dire le programme des
jours heureux, c'està-dire le programme
du conseil national de la résistance
après la guerre qui qui avait rêvé
justement parce que ça c'était une belle
idée après la seconde guerre mondiale où
on s'est rendu compte que national de
résistance, ce sont des hommes des
femmes, beaucoup d'hommes
euh
issu d'horizon de de d'univers politique
assez divers mais qui ont su s'unir
parce que lorsqu'ils ont constaté
l'horreur absolue que représentait la
seconde guerre mondiale avec des
exactions
impensables des des des des degrés
d'inhumanité inimaginable, ils se sont
dit qu'il fallait revenir à l'essentiel.
Ils ont su justement mettre de côté des
des différences anecdotiques pour
imaginer un programme où les êtres
humains ensemble
vivrait autour de magnifiques valeurs
comme la solidarité, comme l'entraide,
le respect de l'autre et cetera. Et
c'est du Conseil national de résistance
que son né la sécurité sociale, l'idée
de la retraite, enfin tout ce qui a
fondé notre modèle social, tout ce qui
est remis en cause aujourd'hui. Sauf que
ces belles idées généreuses, elles ont
été complètement combattues par le
néolibéralisme qui ne pouvait que gagner
pour une bonne et simple raison, c'est
que
les tenants de de ce libéralisme
économique
sont des tricheurs.
Par définition, si vous jouez un jeu
avec quelqu'un qui triche, vous allez
perdre.
Les gilets jaunes, ils ont perdu. C'est
ces gens voulu toujours respecter les
règles du jeu,
embêter personne.
Je sais pas s'ils embêtent personne.
Ilsembêtent un certain nombre de
personnes en tout cas, mais ils sont
perdus parce qu'ils sont bien trop
faibles. Parce qu'ils n'ont pas de ils
sont bien trop faibles en terme de
nombre. Ils n'ont pas de
il y a pas de de de
cadre fort. C'est tout ça est très
dispersé. En plus le gouvernement il ils
ont été ils ont même pas été malins.
C'était c'était juste extrêmement
basique à faire. Mais ils l'ont fait,
c'est divisé pour mieux régner. Ils sont
bien évidemment pressés de d'approcher
certains de ces gilets jaunes, de leur
faire miroiter un certain nombre de
choses, de les inviter à l'Élysée, leur
faire croire qu'il y avait quelque chose
en commun à faire. Enfin, c'était
c'était à la fois extrêmement
euh facile et et cousu de fil blanc,
mais ça a fonctionné. Mais c'est normal
puisque'en face on a des politiques non
professionnelles. On a juste des gens
pleins de bonne foi
et et et tandis que chez Macron ce sont
des spécialistes du mensonge de
l'entoureloupe.
Ce sont plus des gens issus pour la
plupart de du monde de de l'entreprise
donc avec habitué aux règles de la
concurrence la plus féroce ou sans état
d'âme où il y a pas de il y a pas
d'éthique. On a aujourd'hui au
gouvernement des gens qui font de la
politique sans éthique. Donc
le néolibérisme n'a pas d'éthique en
réalité. Et voilà exactement la raison
pour laquelle ce mouvement ne pouvait
que gagner. Sauf que il arrive
aujourd'hui à un stade
où il est à bout de course, il peut pas
aller plus loin. Il a épuisé toutes les
ressources qui ont lui ont permis euh de
grossir de grossir et devenir et de
devenir ultra dominant.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on est dans cette
période de crise, c'est-à-dire que pour
que ce système fonctionne, il faut quand
même qu'il y ait l'adhésion des masses
et ce qui fait d'ailleurs de du
néolibéralisme un totalitarisme. Parce
que le totalitarisme se définit
notamment pas que mais Anna Rent en a
bien parlé son histoire des
totalitarisme se définit notamment par
une adhésion un peu aveugle des masses.
C'est-à-dire, c'est une idéologie
dominante qui détient tous les leviers
du pouvoir avec l'assentiment
plus ou moins plus ou moins marqué des
des masses euh sans possibilité
d'expression d'une d'une idéologie
contraire.
En ce sens, le néolibéralisme est un
totalitarisme. Moi, j'appelle ça un
totalitarisme soft parce que
contrairement au aux deux autres
totalitarisme historique identifié, à
savoir le le fascisme et le stalinisme,
euh bon, il envoie pas encore de manière
très directe les gens en prison ou les
fait pas disparaître si sils sont trop
véhémments. Quoique,
et ça ça fait rebondir un certain nombre
de personnes.
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui dans les
manifestations à la mer dont les
policiers se comportent avec les foules
est pour moi un signe absolument
dramatique d'une évolution des choses
justement c'est-à-dire ce totalitarisme
soft est en train justement je pense de
commencer à montrer son vrai visage. On
arrive dans une phase de répression.
C'est-à-dire que le simple fait
d'organiser des élections constamment,
de rassurer les gens en leur permettant
d'avoir accès à la consommation, au au
produits derniers cris, c'est ça, c'est
comme ça qu'on en dort les masses aussi
hein. Et ben même ça ça commence à plus
tout à fait fonctionner. Les gens se
réveillent, les gens comprennent, les
gens voient que ça marche pas en fait.
Euh mais je sais plus ce que ce quiétait
votre question.
Le néon libéralisme.
Euh ah oui donc je vous dis en tout cas
deux idéologies fortes socialisme,
libéralisme et cetera. les deux. Donc
l'une a échoué dans les années 80, en
tout cas à montrer après des expériences
ratées en URSS ou en Chine par exemple
qui sont les deux les deux expressions
les plus emblématiques d'une forme de
socialisme qui en réalité n'a jamais été
du socialisme euh mais qui a qui ont été
des dictatures et le socialisme n'est
pas censé être une dictature euh ou le
communisme non plus. Euh en tout cas,
ensuite, il y a eu aujourd'hui on
assiste en direct à l'échec du
néolibéralisme et on est dans une phase
de vide idéologique extrêmement
fort,
d'où le désespoir,
d'où la nécessité d'une utopie.
Et et je pense, pardonnez-moi, je
termine juste là-dessus,
que si
parlez autour de vous, je interrogez les
gens de votre entourage, les gens dans
la rue en une journée, demandez-leur
seulement vous êtes heureux, tu es
heureux ? Tu vas bien ? Tu vas bien ?
Il y a au moins trois personnes sur qu
vont commencer dire non ça va pas ça va
pas parce que parce que le travail parce
que le machin il y a une morosité
aujourd'ui qui s'incit qui était pas
celle qui dominait lorsque j'avais même
15 ans. Pourtant déjà, c'était pas
c'était pas l'époque la plus la plus
heureuse qui est connue la France les
années 80. Mais ceci dit, les années 80,
il y avait encore justement ce truc de
c'était les années tapis, les années de
allez, on ose tout euh les mecs qui qui
ont pas de complexe, eux qui vont y
arriver, la vie est belle. C'était des
années finalement pleines de couleur
dans tous les sens du terme, même le
sens littéral et et d'une certaine
manière, il y avait de l'espoir, même si
c'était un espoir
déraisonnable mais bon, il était là, il
y a même plus l'espoir aujourd'hui.
C'estàdire que dans les années 80, les
couleurs c'était du du du jaune du jaune
éclatant, du rose fuchia, des trucs
comme ça. Ça pétait ça pétait aux yeux.
Aujourd'hui, on est dans du gris et du
gris clair et du noir. Ah oui, ici aussi
par exemple.
C'est où le fuchia ? C'est où le jaune
fluo ?
Voilà, c'est comme ça seriew, vous vous
refassiez votre plateau. Et en tout cas,
il faut retrouver ces couleurs. Il faut
retrouver ces couleurs.
Et euh pour moi, il y a que l'écologie
comme projet politique, comme projet de
société, comme projet philosophique qui
est capable de nous redonner ses
couleurs.
On va y revenir. Euh Macron, il a quand
même des électeurs. C'est
il en a pas tant que ça. Bah,
il a au moins 20 % de la population qui
a voté pour lui. Non, 17 %.
Euh alors, faudrait que je reprenne mes
comptes. Vous avez les vous avez les
chiffres euh
de demander à la communauté de nous fa
checker avec Capitaine Fact
de mémoire.
Euh ouais. Alors, attends. De mémoire,
il y a
un électeur sur 5 au premier tour qui a
voté pour lui à peu près.
Euh non, un votant, un votant sur 5 mais
c'est beaucoup moins en terme de
d'électeurs, c'est-à-dire de gens
inscrits sur la ligne les listes
électorales, donc ça fait moins de 20 %.
Mais il y avait un truc intéressant,
c'est qu'on demandait on avait demandé
aux gens à la sortie des urnes euh pour
tous les pour tous les candidats pour
lesquels ils avz voté, est-ce que vous
avez voté par adhésion vraiment ou juste
parce que vous pensez que c'est celui
avec le qui ça se passera le moins mal
quoi ou est-ce que vraiment vous adhérez
à ces idées ? Et et et je crois que pour
les électeurs de Macron, il y a que 30 %
des gens qui avaient voté pour Macron
premier tour qui a répondu que vraiment
c'était un vote d'adhésion. Pour le
reste, tous les autres, c'était un vote
de calcul. Donc on part de 20 % des gens
qui ont mis un bulletin dans l'urne et
on constate que en réalité il y a que 30
% d'entre eux de ces 20 % qui ont voté
vraiment disant "Ce mec est génial."
Donc on arrive je crois peut-être à 10 %
en réalité des des électeurs. Donc c'est
pas énorme et et surtout ce qui est
frappant c'est que
il apporté un modèle il y a quand même
aujourd'hui deux modèles politiques
quand même qui qui s'opposent très
fortement. Il y a le modèle libéral et
le modèle antilibéral.
puisque l'économie c'est un petit peu ce
qui aujourd'hui détermine définit tout
dans notre manière de vivre ensemble. Je
le regrette, je le déplore. Je pense que
c'est pas là qu'on devrait mettre le
curseur. Ça devrait être l'économie
devrait simplement être un moyen au
service de l'humanité. Alors
aujourd'hui, ce sont tous les hommes qui
sont mis au service de de l'économie.
C'est
la croissance.
Oui, mais croissance ou pas croissant.
se trouve que c'est aujourd'hui a une
obsession de la croissance parmi les les
les politiques dominants. Mais
l'économie initialement ne devrait être
qu'un outil pour nous permettre de vivre
ensemble, de produire ce dont on a
besoin pour se se nourrir, s'habiller,
pour se loger. Mais c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe aujourd'hui. L'économie
est devenue le graal, est devenu le cœur
du réacteur. On ne pense qu'économie, on
ne réfléchit que par l'économie. alors
que ça n'a absolument aucun sens. La
seule vraie question et on parle on en
parlait tout à l'heure, c'est
effectivement celle du bonheur. Est-ce
que nous sommes heureux ? C'est quoi
être heureux ? Comment être heureux en
tant qu'individu ? Et quel est notre
rôle aussi sur cette planète en tant
qu'individu, en tant qu'espèce ? Et ça
c'est ce sont des questions qui sont
vêtement négligées par les physiques.
Mais elle est juste là la question. le
jour où on crève.
La seule question à mon avis qui nous je
dis à mon avis parce que je ne suis bien
évidemment pas encore parvenu à ce
moment mais j'imagine que la seule
question qui nous traverse l'esprit à ce
moment-là c'est est-ce que j'ai été
heureux ? Est-ce que j'ai bien fait ?
Est-ce que ça a été utile ? Bon ça fait
trois questions. Euh mais c'est ces
questions là qu'on se pose. On se dit
pas combien j'ai sur mon compte en
banque ou alors si on se pos qu'on a
tout raté qu'on a rien compris.
Donc on a entretenu dans cette illusion
que l'économie est celle qui doit tout
déterminer.
qui doit tout déterminer dans nos vies,
mais c'est une c'est une illusion totale
absolue au service de ceux qui s'en
foutent plein les poches parce que c'est
ce qui les rend heureux. Mais là, on
s'éloigne de votre question qui était et
je me souviens plus.
Bon, on est rentré dans une phase de
divagation intense.
Non, pas de divagation, de digression.
De digression. On n pas encore divagué.
Euh, on était à l'électorat de Macron.
Ah oui, l'électorat de Macron. Ah bah
voilà. Ben on en revient. Et
j'expliquais donc que Ben non, on y
arrive, on y arrive. Euh et j'expliquéis
simplement que Macron défendait un
modèle qui s'appelle le modèle libéral.
Et pendant cette campagne euh
présidentielle, ils étaient deux à
défendre ce modèle libéral. C'était
Macron et Fillon. Tous les autres de
l'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche à
peu près disaient "Non, non, ce modèle
libéral qui nous a amené là où nous
sommes aujourd'hui avec ce chômage entre
6 et 9 millions selon les comptes la
manière qu'on a de compter euh de
français euh avec euh toutes les
injustices sociales, avec les 1 % les
plus riches qui s'enrichissent de plus
en plus, avec le nombre de milliardaires
qui augmente, avec la répartition des
richesses de plus en plus inégal et
cetera et cetera. C'est le modèle
libéral qui nous a amené là. Donc il y
avait quasiment tous les candidats qui
disaient "On ne veut plus de ce modèle
qui est le modèle par exemple qui domine
aujourd'hui les institutions
européenne." Il n'y avait que deux
candidats qui défendaient ce modèle.
C'était Fillon et Macron puisque on
aurait pu avoir chez socialistes Vals
qui défendait du modè. Il avait été
viré. Il avait été viré et puis les les
les sympathisants socialistes avaient
dit "Non non, on préfère Amon qui lui
est antilibéral."
Et donc on se retrouve avec seulement
deux candidats libéraux. Et au premier
tour, ces deux candidats libéraux
lorsque vous mettez leur voix ensemble
font 44 % des suffrages exprimés, ce qui
veut dire à peu près, je crois 33 % des
électeurs.
Donc on a un/ers des électeurs
seulement, 44 % des exprimés qui disent
"On veut un modèle libéral et pourtant"
donc c'est la minorité et pourtant c'est
un candidat
libéral qui a été élu. Donc c'est bien
la preuve que la démocratie chez nous ne
fonctionne pas. La majorité des Français
ne voulaient pas un président qui
continue à promouvoir le modèle libéral
et qui continue àer les plus gros
entrepreneurs et les plus gros et les
banques.
Donc l'électorat de Macron, c'est des
Benet qui ont voté pour
Non mais alors ça j'aime pas. Je
t'insulte personne. Je dis pas Benet. Je
dis pas je je supporte pas. Je je je lis
constamment dans la presse sur les
réseaux sociaux.
A du diable. Non non mais je lis même un
avant de venir chez vous, je lisais sur
Twitter un philosophe un autre
philosophe médiatique qui parlait deel à
quelqu'un d'autre sur Twitter qui vous
êtes un imbécile
qui qui était
Non je vais pas citer de nom parce que
ça va si
on donne des noms.
Ah d'accord. Ben là en l'occurrence, je
pense c'était Raphaë qui disait à
quelqu'un "Je mot doit être parce qu'une
fois plus je l'ai pas pris" mais en gros
ça c'est quelque chose qui était "Vous
êtes un imbécile." Je crois que c'était
ça. Euh j'espère que je cite bien et si
je cite mal je m'en excuse par avance
mais je crois vraiment que c'est ça. Euh
non enfin pourquoi insulter quelqu'un
avec lequel on est en désaccord, avec
lequel on a éventuellement un conflit ?
Je je je déteste ça. Donc les gens qui
ont voté pour Macron ne sont pas des
bonnés. Ce sont des gens qui pensent
sincèrement que soit ils pensent ces
gens pensent sincèrement que Macron est
l'homme qu'il faut aujourd'hui la tête
du pays et c'est leur droit et moi je
pense qu'ils ont tort. Soit ce sont des
gens qui ont compris que Macron était le
candidat qui allait le mieux défendre
leur intérêt. Donc ce sont tous ceux
aujourd'hui qui détiennent tous les
leviers du pouvoir.
Les foulards rouges c'est quoi ?
Je sais pas.
Non je sais pas. J'ai pas je suis comme
ça mais je j'ai pas j'ai pas d'avis sur
eux. J'ai j'ai j'ai lu ce qui se dit sur
je pourrais avoir une sortie comme ça
qui paraît très très spirituelle sur les
foulards rouges. J'en sais rien. J'ai
pas bien compris ce que c'était.
On va vous parler d'utopie et de
réalisme puis on va enchaîner sur
l'écologie. On est dans une société avec
une crise énergétique probable avec un
épuisement des ressources certain. On
est sur une économie qui est sur une
fonction exponentielle avec un
comportement prédateur sur tout ce qui
bouge, ce qui vit, qui a des poils ou
qui peut se faire exploiter.
Et et et on a des politiques qui font un
peu un phénomène de cavalerie. Comment
entretenir une utopie ? Est-ce que
Est-ce que notre système
qui nous a mené aujourd'hui
à vivre tous comme des rois pratiquement
?
Pas tous.
Non non pas surtout pas
je parle je parle pas du tiers monde
pour eux on les voit jamais en France.
Ouais mais
mais vous avez raison il y a dans les
pays qu'on appelle développés en effet
eu des habitudes de vie qui nous
semblent complètement normal et qu'il va
falloir complètement repenser. C'est
très drôle parce que je me permets de de
pas maintenant. Et donc le le on est
mais si je veux c'est mon interview
et
j'ai été très gentil, j'ai j'ai laissé
un petit peu partir êtes très gentil
dans la vie
et donc le Non et ça suffit maintenant
il est pas content parce que je casse
son image. C'est quelqu'un de gentil.
Voilà
donc le le on on se retrouve sur un
problème qui est inextricable
euh difficilement
ralentissable. C'est c'est compliqué
compliqué de le ralentir.
Est-ce que la fuite en avant du
néolibéralisme n'est pas la seule porte
de sortie ? C'est-à-dire pour une élite
pour eux euh
c'est pousser la machine jusqu'au bout
et partir dans l'espace
comme certains films de science-fiction
nous l'ont déjà expliqué. Oui. C'était
ce très beau film. Je crois c'était
Élyséum je crois qui il est génial ce
film. Il dit quelque chose de tellement
vrai, c'est-à-dire que les riches vont
aller habiter dans un endroit protégé.
C'était
c'est l'utopie des riches.
Je pense que c'est le monde vers lequel
on se dirige. C'est extraordinaire, moi
je trouve la la littérature de
d'anticipation. Je trouve qu'on y lit
tellement de choses qui ont été écrites
il y a 50 ou 60 ans et qui sont en train
de se réaliser.
C'est c'est formidable. C'est moi je je
pense que les les les
auteurs de SF, les bons auteurs de SF,
des gens comme Isaac Assassimov, des
gens comme Dick et cetera,
R Bradbury,
Bradbury sont des gens sont sont ceux
qui ont réussi à penser notre société
bien mieux que que les écrivains et les
philosophes depuis un siècle. vraiment
ils ont mieux compris les choses tout
simplement parce qu'ils sont beaucoup
plus intéressés à l'humain et à ce qui
les entoure que la plupart de ceux qui
écrivent aujourd'hui et qui prétendent
nous donner des leçons sur le monde.
Donc petite aparté encore petite
digression mais en tout cas euh mais
bien sûr c'est ça qui est en train de se
dessiner aujourd'hui. un monde où les
riches, les plus riches, les 1 % les
plus riches vont pouvoir eux continuer à
respirer de l'air non pollué, devoir de
l'eau saine, manger sainement et cetera,
partir dans des lieux non pollués en
vacances, habiter dans des zones non
polluées tandis que tous les pauvres eux
se prendront toute la merde dans la
gueule.
Voilà, tout en accaparant les tous les
revenus, le maximum de revenus, ce qui
est bien évidemment corrélé puisque
c'est parce qu'ils ont tous les revenus
qui vont pouvoir s'offrir tous ces
services qui permettront de rester de
rester en vie le plus longtemps possible
en bonne santé.
Euh vous parliez de crise des ressources
? Oui, il y a en fait aujourd'hui la
logique de l'exploitation qui est
poussée à son paroxisme. On exploite
tout ce qu'on peut exploiter,
tout. On essaie de se faire de l'argent
sur absolument tout. L'idée même de
gratuité n'est plus n'est même plus
quelque chose qui est considéré.
C'est-à-dire que celui qui fait quelque
chose de gratuit et considéré comme un
bon là je vais utiliser ce mot
c'est une attaque personnelle. C'est
quoi ?
Parce que nous on est en gratuit nous
les gens nous financent que par don.
Non c'est surtout pas une attaque parce
que moi je je je trouve que c'est ça la
solution dans voilà on en revient au
livre dans Utopie. J'imagine ou c'est
trop fort. Vous êtes trop fort. Je sais
que c'est c'était le but he de votre
question. Euh j'imagine une société où
la gratuité est quelque chose de répandu
pour beaucoup de choses en tout cas pas
pour tout parce que j'imagine que
l'argent je fais pas partie de ceux qui
disent qu'il faut absolument supprimer
l'argent parce que je pense que l'argent
a en plus de ces fonctions originelles
euh qui ont été définies déjà par
Aristote à l'époque, c'est-à-dire unité
de compte euh euh unité de de de valeur,
moyen de de paiement, euh moyen
d'échange.
Justement, c'est quelque chose de très
utile l'argent et ça peut même
ça peut même limiter la consommation le
fait de donner des salaires qu'on dit
tiens si tout à coup tout était gratuit
comme parce que sur l' Thomas Mort tout
était gratuit. Je dis bah non, c'est un
défaut si tout est gratuit parce que ça
veut dire que chacun il reste précipité
pour consommer un maximum puisque tout
serait apporté. Donc c'est bien aussi
d'avoir dire de limiter des revenus qui
nous qui limitent donc la capacité
d'avoir des d'avoir des choses. Euh mais
pardon, pourquoi je vous par
Excusez-moi, en fait tellement de
digressions que j'en oublié à chaque
fois les questions. Euh là la question
était sur même vous vous savez plus
euh je ne sais plus de quoi on parlait.
Pourquoi je vous parlais de l'argent ?
En fait vous en foutez, il s'en fout.
C'est c'est pas bien. Je ne sais plus.
Bon, on va trouver une autre question.
Voilà,
on revient on revient à la soutenabilité
sociétale, l'argent moyen de stocker de
la calorie, d'échanger les entre les
gens.
Ouais.
Euh, on a on a ce ce 1 %.
Je sais pourquoi. Je finis ma question.
l'interview la plus décousue de
Syerview, c'est avec moi. Non,
j'imaginais en revanche dans Utopia qui
est la gratuité, pardon, voilà la
gratuité pour un certain nombre de
choses et je trouve que les les biens
culturels par exemple en font partie. On
devrait trouver des capacités de
financer les journaux mais aussi des
sites comme le vôtre ou en tout cas des
des choses qui font partie de la
culture, faire en sorte que toutes ces
choses-là soient accessibles comme des
comme des biens essentiels. C'est-à-dire
que dans une la société que j'imagine,
l'État qui récolte les impôts, dans ma
société idéale, on paye toujours des
impôts. l'État a bien besoin d'argent
pour vivre et pour faire fonctionner la
société, pour faire fonctionner les
hôpitaux, les routes, tout ce dont nous
servons tous les jours. J'imagine qu'il
trouve les moyens de faire en sorte
qu'un certain nombre de services sont
complètement gratués. Alors bien
évidemment, on déprivatise tout ce qui
est lié au vivant, hein. Plus plus de
brevet sur le vivant. L'eau, elle est
gratuite, c'est pas normal qu'on paye
l'eau, par exemple. Mais de la même
manière, j'imaginais que chaque citoyen
peut avoir accès à des journaux
gratuitement, un certain nombre de
journaux. Donc on finance la presse, on
aide ses journaux à vivre, on paye les
abonnements au au passe. Non
non, ça avait raison. Vrai, c'est que
l'État paye beaucoup donne beaucoup
d'argent à beaucoup de journaux.
Le monde le monde et toutes les
l'oligarchie touche, on est tout à fait
d'accord. Sauf que c'est pour l'instant
c'est que dans un sens et puis l'État ne
fait pas vivre tous les médias.
Il en fait vivre beaucoup ceci dit mais
pas forcément les les petits
indépendants ceux qui
nous on a pris 50000 € pour les 6
derniers mois
c'est vrai
pour payer des techniciens
ça va c'est c'est enfin 6 mois oui ça
fait à peu près 10000 balles par mois
bon mais en revanche et vous un système
de gratuité mais que qui est pas
forcément le plus simple à faire vivre
j'imagine. J'imagine en tout cas
compliqué. Ouais
voilà
votre monde idéal on régule les
naissances.
Ouais,
en tout cas, on on se pose la question.
Je n'ai pas parce que je ne suis pas un
spécialiste de la question, je n'ai pas
imaginer très concrètement comment on
s'y prenait parce qu'il y a tous les
équilibres à réinventer. C'est-à-dire
qu'on sait très bien que il y a des
endroits de la planète où on fait plus
d'enfants que d'autres. En revanche, la
question euh du nombre d'habitants sur
cette planète est une question
essentielle euh à laquelle refuse de
réfléchir pour l'instant les politiques.
Alors même que euh les 15000
scientifiques qui avaient lancé un appel
très important il y a maintenant près de
2 ans dans une tribune qui a été
diffusée dans 184 pays avait placé la
question démographique au cœur de leur
préoccupation. Il faut quand même se
souvenir qu'en en 1800, il y avait 1
milliard d'habitants sur terre.
en 1800 1 milliard, nous sommes
aujourd'hui 7 milliards et demi. Euh
lorsque je suis né, il y avait 3
milliards et demi d'habitants sur terre.
C'estàd que la population mondiale a
doublé depuis ma naissance
exponentielle.
Si ça continue comme ça, bon alors les
prévisions
sont variables. On prévoit à peu près 10
milliards de personnes en 2100,
mais certaines prédictions vont jusqu'à
15 milliards. On sait pas en fait.
d'illion le nombre le comment
d' 10 500 millions ?
Ah oui, parce que on va tous mourir. Bah
je sais pas si on
mais euh ça pose un problème énorme. On
est trop nombreux sur cette planète, on
est trop dans les grandes villes. Ça
pose tous les problèmes évidemment de
pollution mais de vivre ensemble aussi.
Plus on est les uns sur les autres. Ça
fait partie, ça c'est des questions de
naturaliste en tout cas de d'étologiste.
C'est-à-dire
l'être humain est un animal. On sait
très bien que les toutes les populations
animales s'autorégulent,
qu'elles ont besoin toutes d'un minimum
d'espace pour vivre, que chaque individu
de chaque espèce a besoin d'un minimum
d'espace pour vivre, pour ne pas rentrer
en situation de conflit, pour préserver
les ressources et cetera. Ça une
question que nous humains ne nous ne
nous posons absolument pas pour
l'instant. Il faut se la poser. Donc
bien évidemment, ça veut dire réfléchir
au nombre d'enfants que l'on fait. Se
poser la question également des échanges
sur la PN. C'est pour ça moi je crois à
la à l'abolition des frontières
euh à terme. Ça veut pas dire qu'il
restera pas des frontières
administratives basiques pour organiser
les échanges ou les lieux de vie. Bien
évidemment, il peut y avoir des échelons
comme des régions, comme des États et
cetera, mais pas des lieux fermés, des
lieux d'échange. Les réfugiés
climatique, on sait très bien maintenant
que ça va être des centaines de millions
de personnes dans les décennies qui
viennent. Des centaines de millions de
personnes dans les décennies qui
viennent. Aucun état, aucun gouvernement
ne veut réfléchir sérieusement à la
question.
Il y a la Hongrie qui commence à mettre
des barbelés. Il y a les États-Unis qui
mettent des murs.
Pour l'instant, tout va dans le sens
contraire. les seuls qui réfléchissent,
c'est pour aller dans le sens contraire
et dire je me barricade chez moi. C'est
exactement l'inverse qu'il faut faire.
Il faut que l'humanité c'est une unité.
Enfin, c'est ça peut paraître
extrêmement banal de dire c'est kit.
Ouais. Ouais. Enfin, c'est une réalité.
C'est une unité qui ensuite s
diversifiée.
Euh le Mustaapien, enfin notre origine
se trouve en Afrique, vous le savez. On
vient tous d'un petit groupe de quelques
milliers de personnes
en Afrique qui a quitté l'Afrique il y a
quelques dizaines de milliers d'années.
C'est tout récent. Et puis ensuite ça a
colonisé l'ensemble de la planète
en prenant on a pris des formes un peu
diverses mais on est tous issus
exactement des mêmes ancêtres, des mêmes
cousins.
Et je ne comprends pas cette notion. La
notion d'altérité est très importante
dans la mesure elle nous permet nous
parce que c'est un peu notre paradoxe.
C'està-dire que nous en tant
qu'individu, on doit s'affirmer.
Le malheur de chacun d'entre nous est
notamment issu du fait de ne pas être
reconnu en tant qu'individu.
On est malheureux dans sa vie si euh
notre employeur ne nous reconnaît pas
nos mérites professionnels. Si on n pas
quelqu'un qui nous aime dans notre vie
quotidienne, soit de la famille, soit sa
femme, son mari. C'estàdire quelqu'un
qui nous reconnaît une qualité en tant
qu'individu. C'est le c'est l'un des
profes de l'être humain. C'est la raison
pour laquelle une société qui uniformise
tout et qui oublie de vous penser en
tant qu'individu est une société qui ne
peut créer que du malheur. Mais en même
temps, c'est la c'est c'est cette double
énergie qu'il faut gérer et il faut une
équation qu'on doit résoudre. En même
temps, il faut comprendre l'unité
profonde de l'espèce humaine et que nous
sommes tous fondamentalement les mêmes.
Toi, tu as lu Christ Murti toi. Non,
mais c'est et c'est c'est euh mais j'ai
lu plein d'autres penseurs qui qui
disent des choses un peu similaires. Et
donc je trouve que le le
modèle politique dominant aujourd'hui
dans les pays occidentaux, on le voit
avec Trump, on le voit en France
aujourd'hui parce qu'en réalité
lorsqu'on agrège les voix, on voit bien
que c'est un un modèle très conservateur
aujourd'hui qui domine qui domine le le
les idées. cette idée. Ah là là, on se
réfugie derrière notre tradition, on se
on se referme chez chez nous, on se
recroque vie sur nous-même, tout ça va
complètement à rebour de notre histoire,
notre histoire sur le long terme.
Je j'ouvre une parenthèse pour la
communauté. Allez chercher sur YouTube
ou sur un autre autre plateforme, vous
tapez Krishna Murti OU 1985. Vous allez
trouver une une conférence de pour la
remise de la médaille de la paix l'ONU.
parenthèse fermée. Continue.
Il se la pète un peu. C'est curv parfois
c'est une blague.
Tu vas pas faire le mal longtemps.
Bon, on va passer aux questions
internet. Euh
Mathieu,
alors le libéralisme uniformise et en
même temps valorise l'individualisme.
Est-ce contradicto est est-ce en
contradiction une contradiction ? Bah
c'est c'est drôle parce que c'est
vraiment relié à ce que on se disait à
l'instant.
Euh
c'est euh c'est une contradiction euh
disons que est-ce que c'est une Oui,
c'est une forme de contradiction.
Je sais pas, j'essaie de réfléchir. Oui,
parce que souvent je mets beaucoup de
temps avant de répondre aux questions.
Ça tombe bien ici. On est tranquille, on
a le temps.
Le libéralisme en tout cas tel qu'il
s'exprime aujourd'hui
est un modèle qui qui dit à chaque
individu fais ce que tu veux pour y
arriver.
Oublie toutes les règles, fonce, écrase
les autres.
Donc je crois que là où il y a
uniformisation, c'est dans cette
règle-là tout simplement
que ensuite par des par mécanismes
économiques très classiques, on se
retrouve avec des
des agrégats
économiques très forts, très puissants
qui se développent. Ce qui fait que
puisque ça en fait c'est c'est très
enfin je réfléchis le le libéralisme
économique ne protège pas l'individu ne
protège pas du tout l'individu c'est
tout le contraire puisqu'il n'y a pas de
règle il y a pas de règles pour le
protéger
et
ça va permettre simplement à certains
d'accumuler de plus en plus de puissance
de moyens d'argent et cetera pour
dominer tous les autres c'est ça le
principe même du du libéralisme. Et donc
de ce fait, ça empêche la conservation
ou l'émergence de tous les modèles
alternatifs. Donc c'est un système qui
nie complètement l'individu en réalité.
Donc il y a peut-être une liberté
illusoire au début en disant parce que
souvent quand je réfléchis c'est je suis
comme certains présentateurs de JT, je
regarde en l'air. Non, c'est c'est
qu' on des grands cheveux.
À qui pensez-vous ? Non non,
le libéralisme donne une illusion de
liberté.
première,
mais c'est une illusion. Tout est faux
parce qu'en réalité ça vous empêche
d'être vraiment fondamentalement
original. Ça vous empêche euh de de
développer des modèles qui
n'appartiennent qu'à vous-même. Ça ça
détruit toute possibilité de choix très
rapidement
euh de choix de travail, de choix de
loisirs, de de euh de choix de vie tout
simplement.
Autre question internet. Il y a aussi
des utopies technophiles. Le rêveur, les
rêveurs ne sont pas forcément du bon
côté. Si point d'interrogation le
transhumanisme par exemple
Laurent Alexandre et tout ça.
Pensez-vous qu'on peut avoir une
connaissance infinie dans un monde fini
? Une croissance pardon. Pensez-vous
qu'on peut avoir une croissance infinie
dans un monde fini ? N'est-ce pas une
utopie ?
Ah non, ben la croissance j'en parle,
c'est c'est l'une des plus grandes
utopies. Alors, on revient aussi à des
thèmes du livre qui est que l'utopie
n'est pas du tout du côté où l'on pense.
C'està-dire que si l'utopie parce qu'on
il y a plusieurs manières de définir le
mot utopie en gros deux sens à ce mot.
Soit c'est le sens littéraire, une
utopie et un système de société jugée
idéale. Donc c'est c'est un système
politique. Par exemple, la République de
Platon est une utopie. L'utopie de
Thomas Mor, c'est une utopie par
définition. Donc c'est on imagine
comment vivraient les hommes avec
certaines règles. On appelle ça une
utopie. Et puis l'utopie, telle qu'on
l'entend aujourd'hui devenu un nom
commun étant un rêve, une idée qui vous
guide mais qui est complètement
irréaliste, quelque chose qui est
déconnecté de la réalité. pas et c'est
surtout comme ça qu'on emploie ce mot
aujourd'hui. Et en ce sens, le système
dans lequel on vit aujourd'hui est une
utopie totale puisque c'est une on est
dans un système politique et économique
qui méprise complètement les faits,
c'est-à-dire par exemple la crise
écologique. C'està-dire qu'on est
aujourd'hui avec des politiques qui euh
surexploitent toujours le vivant en
oubliant tous les signaux d'alerte qui
sont reçus de manière hebdomadaire.
On est dans un système qui ignore la
misère sociale, le malheur des des
citoyens. Donc on est dans une utopie
totale. À chaque fois, on compte mais
tout va bien et c'est le meilleur
système possible. Donc c'est ça
l'utopie. L'utopie, le mensonge est là
et la croissance par exemple est par
définition une utopie. C'est parce que
le le l'internaute qui nous pose la
question effectivement a tout résumé
parce que les ressources sont limitées.
La taille de la planète est limitée.
Cette planète on a on en aacune.
L'astrophysicien Stephen Hawking disait
euh qu'il nous faudrait trouver une
nouvelle planète d'ici 500 ans euh parce
qu'on l'aura complètement bousillé la
nôtre. on aura tout exploité,
surexploité. Et donc et c'est là l'une
des limites fondamentales du
libéralisme, c'estàd cette idée de
croire que il faut toujours produire
plus, produire plus, produire plus,
produire plus pour créer l'économie dans
laquelle nous serons tous heureux.
Ça n'est plus possible aujourd'hui et
c'est une utopie de croire que qu'on
peut continuer à avoir la croissance
comme une espèce d'étoile du berger.
C'est pas possible. Alors pourquoi tous
les politiques brandissent
la croissance ? Parce que nos politiques
ont tous été formés. D'abord la plupart
de nos politiques sont issues des mêmes
milieux sociaux très favorisés.
La
lesquel bah les ce sont souvent ce sont
souvent des gens qui ont fait des études
supérieures qui ont des regardz la
composition de l'Assemblée nationale
vous verrez. Ce sont des
des hommes blancs un peu gros.
Ah, vous avez remarqué que avec Macron,
ils ont maigri
ils ont les dents qui qui ont poussé.
Je sais pas. Mais en tout cas, il y a il
y a dans les codes Macron l'idée que le
le le l'élu macroniste doit avoir l'air
un peu en forme, pas trop vieux et un
peu et aller à la salle de sport de
temps en temps. Mais euh non, il y a que
nos hommes politiques ont tous été
formatés
dans les mêmes écoles et dans les mêmes
formations. Et ces formations, ces
écoles sont complètement ignorantes des
réalités du monde. Ce sont des écoles de
gestionnaires qui fonctionnent sur de
vieux modèles. Et par exemple, Macron
est complètement inculte en réalité de
de de la réalité de cette planète
aujourd'hui. Le monde de Macron, c'est
ce qu'il a vu, les gens qu'il côtoi
qu'il côtoi depuis ses études et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui sont des financiers, des
banquiers, des chefs d'entreprise mais
pas des petites entreprises,
des des gens méritants qui qui qui suent
toute l'année pour gagner un petit
bénéfice. Il y a aussi beaucoup de fils
d'eau parce que ça c'est très français,
beaucoup moins américain mais très
français chez nous. C'est le népotisme
et népotisme familial très important,
l'héritage. Donc euh les gens qui ne
dominent ne côent pas toute la journée
que des gens qui vont extrêmement bien,
qui gagnent beaucoup d'argent
euh et qui
sont à milieu des problématiques réelles
de notre planète aujourd'hui et de 90 %
des gens qui l'habitent. C'est raison
pour laquelle ils sont incapables
d'imaginer d'autres modèles. D'autant
que ils sont avec des gens qui leur
demandent toujours de prolonger
certaines politiques ou d'en mettre en
place d'autres qui vont être à leur
avantage.
On fait quoi ? On leur coupe la tête.
Non non non, moi je suis pas je suis pas
un révolutionnaire sanguinaire, je suis
vraiment un partenant de la nonvolence.
Donc je voudrais
anesthésie avant
décharge une petite décharge.
C non je crois vraiment au alors il y a
de je ne sais pas la colère à un moment
s' enfin à un moment je sais même les
gens les plus raisonnables effectivement
peuvent tout à coup
éclater
se mettre très fortement en colère parce
qu'ils ont sentiment que que qu'ils sont
pas entendus qu' qu'il y a rien que la
raison permet de faire avancer et
cetera. J'espère qu'on en arrivera pas
là, mais j'ai bon espoir. J'ai enfin
j'ai bon espoir, j'ai pas bon espoir. Je
suis très pessimiste sur les sur les sur
les décennies à venir.
Je vois que tu te frottes les yeux, tu
arrives à dormir avec
J'ai l'espoir j'ai j'ai l'espoir que que
qu'un mouvement puisse émerger. Il est
en train d'émerger dans la société mais
simplement il y a beaucoup de gens qui
essayent de l'étouffer. Ce mouvement par
les voies démocratiques va pouvoir
imposer des nouvelles règles. Mais je
crois que je je vais rappelle ça de mon
vivant. Je crois hélas qu'on va d'abord
passer par des crises majeures
euh qui vont être extrêmement
destructrices, des crises sociales, des
crises sanitaires, des crises
environnementales.
Je crois qu'il va y avoir des émeutes.
Euh
euh enfin il y a plein de choses, il y a
plein de choses pas enfin ça c'est les
collapsologues qui en parleront mieux
que moi, mais je suis pas mais j'ai
voilà, il faut quand même que je
continue à à entretenir un certain
espoir, notamment celui que qu'on peut
essayer de faire avancer les idées, même
si je dois avouer que je suis de plus en
plus pessimiste et de plus en plus
réaliste.
Je sais pas si je suis réaliste.
J'essaie de l'être lorsque je je parle
de quelque chose. J'essaie toujours
d'appuyer ma pensée non pas sur une
croyance, donc sur quelque chose
d'irrationnel, mais sur des faits
scientifiques que je crois énormément à
aux apports de la science
dans la réflexion politique. La science
au sens très large du terme, je pense
que c'est elle qui doit nous expliquer
quelles sont les mesures à prendre et la
science et la philosophie qui qui faut
qui doit fonctionner de paix.
L'éthique, la morale, c'est quoi pour
toi ?
L'éthique et la morale, bah d'abord,
c'est quelque chose de fondamental. Je
suis très très conscient pour ça.
Et euh l'éthique, c'est ce qui devrait
guider chacun d'entre nous. Alors
officiellement nous explique que c'est
vachement bien les lois par exemple
c'est une expression de l'éthique.
Alors les lois c'est ce qui fait
société. Donc on pourrait considérer que
l'éthique et la morale c'est ce qui nous
fait homme et ce qui nous permet de
vivre ensemble. Puis en même temps, tout
est fait pour nous détourner de
l'éthique et de la morale. Et en tout
cas, la plupart des lois qui sont mises
en place ne ne respecte pas finalement
cette éthique et cette morale dont on
nous explique pourtant quel est notre
ciment, quels sont notre ciments.
L'éthique, c'est tout simplement
donner un sens à notre vie en
établissant une échelle de valeur à
laquelle on va essayer de se conformer
lorsqu'on a des choix à faire.
Pour moi, c'est le plus important.
C'est-à-dire que rien na de sens.
C'est-à-dire gagner 10000 balles ou
20000 balles à la fin du mois.
Combien tu gagnais chez ?
Je gagnais
les deux premières années, je gagnais
€ brut par émission.
Il rigole.
Et la dernière année 1500 par émission
brute.
Donc quand il y a pas d'émission, on
n'était pas payé évidemment. Donc euh
oui, c'était c'est des il faut être très
honnête, c'est très bien payé par
rapport à beaucoup de gens sur euh en
France, mais c'est pas les sommes euh
démesurées que certains ont pu imaginer,
mais voilà. En tout cas, toute somme
gagnée
en étant pas fier du travail qu'on qu'on
a qu'on a fait pour acquérir cette somme
pour moi me paraît inintéressante.
C'està dire que l'éthique c'est être
contente de ce qu'on a fait dans sa
journée lorsqu'on se couche. C'est de
dire tiens j'étais fidèle à moi-même
j'étais fidèle à un certain nombre de
valeurs, je ne me suis pas trahi. C'est
essayer de se dire quel être humain je
je dois être si je veux que cette
humanité aille dans le bon sens.
Est-ce que j'y arrive ou pas ? On sait
tous, on a tout, on s'est tous tu à des
moments de notre vie. On a été obligé
parce qu'on est bien obligé de bouffer,
on est bien obligé de travailler. On a
tous accepté de se taire devant un chef
qui qui nous insupportait, dont on
savait qu'il avait tort, dont
onapréciait pas les méthodes, dont
onapréciait pas les objectifs. Et on se
sittu. Et je pense que
c'est l'une des énormes difficultés
aussi qui nous tiraille, c'est réussir à
à exister, à vivre tout simplement, à
faire vivre sa famille tout en
respectant les valeurs auxquelles on
croit fondamentalement, mais en ayant
les moyens de les imaginer aussi ces
valeurs parce que tout est fait pour
nous les faire oublier qu'on doit avoir
des valeurs et qu'on doit avoir une
éthique.
Autre question internet. Pourquoi
l'écologie ne serait pas un nouveau
totalitarisme ?
Elle peut l'être. Le totalitarisme,
c'est en réalité une manière d'imposer
une idée à des gens qui n'y croient pas,
qui n'en veulent pas, qui ne peuvent pas
la réfuter, qui ne peuvent pas faire des
contrepropositions.
L'idée n'est pas d'imposer
un nouveau modèle de société à des gens
qui le réprouvent complètement. L'idée,
c'est simplement de réussir à convaincre
la majorité des gens de manière
complètement démocratique que pour
l'intérêt de tous, il y a des nouveaux
choix de société à faire. Et l'idée
c'est d'avoir les moyens d'expliquer
cela. Dans le livre, j'explique par
exemple, si on prend le nucléaire, il y
a un sondage récent qui disait que 47 %
des Français souhaitent la fermeture des
centrales. Bon, est-ce qu'ils ont raison
? Est-ce qu'ils ont tort ? Le minimum
serait aujourd'hui qu'on a un débat
démocratique sur la question, un grand
débat. Si la moitié des Français
aujourd'hui considèrent que le nucléaire
c'est plus la solution.
Si la moitié des Français considèrent
que le nucléaire c'est plus la solution,
mais ils sont pas au courant.
Non. Voilà. On sait rien.
Peut pas faire qu'on peut pas faire
autrement.
Qu'on peut pas faire autrement. Si si,
on peut faire autrement.
Comment ? Bah, on développe pas les
énergies renouvelables. Après, on peut
prendre chacune des énergies
renouvelables. Le cas des éoliennes, par
exemple, c'est pas la même chose que le
solaire. Il y a des d'autres
problématiques sur les éoliennes qui
n'existe pas pour le solaire. Il y a de
la géothermie, il y a la biomasseque. Il
y a beaucoup de choses à mettre en
place, à imaginer. Ce sont des
programmes ambitieux, audacieux qui nous
demandent une réelle volonté
gouvernementale qu'on a absolument pas
en France puisqu'il y a 40 ans, on a
fait le choix du nucléaire, qu'on a tout
misé là-dessus et que maintenant on est
super emmerdé parce qu'en plus des
mantelés des centrales ça coûte super
cher et que mais en revanche ce qui est
intéressant c'est d'avoir ce débat
d'avoir des vrais débats, expliquer le
vrai coût du nucléaire en France en
incluant notamment celui du
diamantellement des centrales ou de des
mises aux normes au bout de 40 ans et
cetera. Ce qui n'est absolument pas
fait. Ce que je veux simplement
expliquer, c'est qu'il y a sur beaucoup
beaucoup de sujets la nécessité de
permettre à chaque citoyen d'avoir
toutes les informations qui permettent
de se faire son idée. Sur un sujet que
je connais bien et et qui me touche au
plus haut point, c'est celui des droits
des animaux, donc celui de
l'alimentation. Il y a beaucoup de
contre vérité aujourd'hui qui sont
véhiculé par les instances
gouvernementales, les instances
sanitaires.
Par exemple, l'idée, si vous allez
aujourd'hui dans les école, il est écrit
dans les recommandations
gouvernementales qu'il faut qu'il y ait
des protéines animales dans les menus
des enfants. Des protéines animales,
c'est faux. Faut pas de protéine animale
pour être en bonne santé. Donc mais
simplement c'est écrit parce que ça
répond au besoin de de lobby puissant en
France. L'agriculture en l'occurrence.
Le salon de l'agriculture, tu as kiffé ?
Bah non.
Pourquoi tu voudrais que j'ai kiffé ?
Non mais qu'est-ce que tu veux ? C'est
une grande foire. C'est très compliqué
l'histoire des agriculteurs. Je ne suis
pas contre les agriculteur
pour moi. C'est une c'est J'ai même
envie que dans mon je pense c'est un
combat mais oui, on va dire combat en
tout cas dans ma mes préoccupations pour
pour les animaux pour pour
l'antispécisme, j'aurais vraiment envie
de travailler avec les agriculteurs dont
beaucoup d'entre eux sont des victimes
du système actuel. Les paysans meurent
depuis 40 ans. Le nombre de paysans en
France a été diminué par 4 depuis 40
ans. Paysans hein, le paysan en tant que
tel est a quasiment disparu, a été
remplacé par des ouvriers, par des
employés de l'industrie, mais en été le
paysan lui-même aujourd'hui a
complètement disparu. Tu sais très bien
les les éleveurs sont des gens qui pour
la plupart d'entre eux gagnent
extrêmement mal leur vie. C'est chez a
culteur qu'on a le taux suicide le plus
élevé dans toutes les de toutes les
professions en France. Euh c'est en plus
l'agriculture est un métier qui est et
l'élevage en particulier qui qui ne vit
que par les subventions subvention
européennes. C'est un système qui marche
complètement sur la tête qu'il faut
complètement revoir.
Comment ça se fait que les agriculteurs
bio, ils reçoivent pas leur subvention
depuis un certain nombre d'années ?
Et j'en sais rien moi. Non mais je sais
pas.
Question d'internet. Comment comment se
passer des engrais organiques qui
fournissent que que fournissent les
animaux ? Comment sortir du modèle
polyculture élevage dans les cycles
agronomiques
sont efficaces ?
Je te refais la question.
En gros, c'est ce qu'on a besoin. Ça
c'est peut-être la question qui dit que
il y a des gens qui pensent qu'on a
absolument besoin d'élever des animaux.
Véganisme égal engrais chimique.
Voilà, c'est ça. Non, pas forcément. Pas
du tout. Il y a des euh des méthodes
tout à fait naturelles. D'abord, il y a
des engrais verts, c'est-à-dire un
certain nombre de
de végétaux que l'on fait pousser sur
les champs et qui en fait fertilise les
sols. Ça c'est des vieilles méthodes
très naturelles. On connaît beaucoup
comme ça d'engravert. Euh
ensuite si vraiment imaginons, je
vraiment plus court pour cette cette
question. Imaginons qu'on ait vraiment
besoin des animaux pour fertiliser.
Bon, d'accord. Vous savez, les
troupeaux, ils ont pas été inventés par
l'homme, hein. Les troupeaux, ils
existent depuis euh des millions
d'années, depuis que les animaux euh
existent, depuis que les gros animaux
existent. Bah d'accord, bah conservons
quelques troupeaux, enfin conservons les
troupeaux de toute façon. Mais par
contre, on est pas obligé de les tuer
les animaux pour autant.
C'estàd qu'on va voir des troupeaux à
Versailles.
Pourquoi pas ? D'ailleurs, il y a déjà
des troupeaux à Versailles.
Alors, que fait-on ? Mais
il y a des troupeaux à Versailles et des
troupeaux de mouton, par exemple.
Ouais, clairement. Ouais. Euh,
mais c'est vrai.
Ouais. Non mais c'est
c'est
que fait Ouais ouais avec des avec des
sertes écossais aussi euh que fait-on
des animaux d'élevage aujourd'hui ?
Non non mais des vrais moutons hein
c'est pas une blague. C'était pas
c'était pas une métaphore.
Quand vous êtes balé dans le parc du
château, vous pouvez voir les petits
troupeaux de mouton pardon avec des
certains écossais.
Non non des vrais moutons, des animaux
avec de la laine.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait des élevages
d'animaux des
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui des
animaux d'élevage ? On les lâche ? On
fait quoi ? On ouvre les barrières.
On les laisse en liberté.
Euh, on fait quoi ?
D'abord, il y a beaucoup trop d'animaux
d'élevage aujourd'hui sur cette planète
qui prennent énormément énormément de
place. Euh
je suis en train de de me remémorer les
chiffres, je voudrais pas vous dire de
bêtises.
Euh sur la biomasse des mammifères
aujourd'hui sur cette planète, 60 %
c'est des animaux d'élevage,
36 % c'est des humains et 4 % seulement
ce sont des animaux sauvages. C'estàd
qu'on a complètement détruits.
Tu tu comptes ce qu'il y a dans les sols
aussi ou
la biomasse animale ? Non, je te parle
non, je te parle de biomasse non je
parle uniquement je te parle uniquement
des mammifères,
la biomasse des mammifères.
Il y a beaucoup beaucoup trop de toute
façon d'animaux d'élevage aujourd'hui
qui sont élevés pour nourrir les hommes.
On fait quoi ?
On arrête de les produire.
C'est pas compliqué. C'estàd que ce sont
des animaux qui ne naissent que pour
finir dans nos assiettes.
L'espérance de vie d'une vache, c'est
combien de temps
? 15 ans à peu près, ça peut arriver à
18 ans.
Donc pendant 15 ans, on fait du baby
sitting de vaches.
Bah, on les produit plus. C'està-dire
qu'en gros les vaches avant c'était des
oroc he c'était là. Mais les animaux
n'ont pas besoin de nous. Pourquoi faire
du babysitting de vache ? Les animaux
n'ont pas besoin des êtres humains. Les
animaux non humains, j'entends. Les
animaux ont été domestiqués il y a les
premiers il y a 15000 ans environ. Euh
les chiens en l'occurrence euh enfin les
loups qui sont devenus des chiens.
Mais 15000 c'est rien sur l'échelle de
de de l'histoire de la vie. Ces animaux
vivaient très très bien sans nous et ils
continueront à vivre sans nous. Après,
il y aura des réserves naturelles dans
lesquelles on pourra les laisser en paix
tranquillou. on pourra avoir des
relations euh bénéfiques
euh dans un certain nombre de cas avec
quelques animaux avec lesquels on pourra
continuer à avoir euh des relations
quotidiennes. Il se trouve que
effectivement aujourd'hui il y a par
exemple des chiens de compagnie ou des
chats de compagnie dont on peut imaginer
continuer euh à s'occuper parce que la
relation est bénéfique. Si effectivement
le chien est heureux, le chat est
heureux, pourquoi pas ? Pourquoi s'en
priver ? Mais tous ces animaux-là n'ont
rien à faire dans notre contact direct.
Ce sont des animaux qui vivent sans
nous. En principe,
le chien le chien c'est du moins le loup
s'est rapproché de l'homme pour
bénéficier de ses reste.
Ouais.
Et et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je dis que
dans certains cas de figure, je ne fais
pas partie des végan qui disent "Nous ne
devons plus avoir aucun rapport avec les
animaux non humains."
Plus de chien de traîneau, plus
d'équitation.
Non non non, bien sûr, bien sûr. Puisque
là ce sont des esclaves, ils sont
exploités ces animaux-là.
Alors, il y a des cas où c'est limite
parce que on peut considérer qu'il y a
un service rendu. Il faut être tout à
fait honnête. Si on prend l'exemple des
chats, un un chat de compagnie euh qui
vit dans votre maison, à qui vous allez
Pourquoi il se marre ?
Je pense au chat de ma belle- sœur.
Alors euh à qui vous ouvrez le matin la
la la porte, qui rentre le soir et
cetera. Bon bah s'il est pas écrasé par
nature, il a une expérience de vie
peut-être de 15 ans ce qui est super
chouette. Or, c'est vrai que les études
montrent que si vous laissez ce chat en
totale liberté, c'estd sans aucune
enfin, il est en liberté mais si vous le
laissez vraiment complètement
indépendant de de de toute interaction
humaine, un chat sauvage, il a peut-être
que 5 6 ans de vie de moyenne de vie
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de risques de
maladie de de de de voilà de qu' lui
arrive qu'il soit écrasé et cetera et
cetera. Donc parfois effectivement cette
idée de protection peut être
intéressante pour certains animaux.
Alors, question internet. N'est-ce pas
politiquement plus efficace de se battre
contre l'élevage industriel que contre
l'élevage tout court ?
Ce sont deux combats qui se rejoignent à
un moment mais qui sont pas les mêmes.
C'est-à-dire que les ceux qui sont
nombreux aujourd'hui à lutter contre
l'élevage industriel disent "Bah moi, je
veux une viande de qualité. Je veux une
viande de qualité. Je veux pas qu'il y
ait une antibiotique dans ma viande. OK
? Et puis bon, l'animal s'il peut avoir
été pas trop maltraité, c'est mieux.
D'accord. Très bien.
Oui, c'est mieux. C'est mieux un élevage
qu'on va qualifier de de de familial,
c'est mieux effectivement qu'un grand
hangar dans lequel des des bêtes
s'entassent qu'un élevage intensif. Bien
sûr, c'est mieux. Mais il n reste pas
moins vrai que l'animal est toujours tué
au bout de 6 mois ou de 4 mois et
cetera. Or, c'est pas le combat des
antispécistes. Nous, le combat qui est
le nôtre est celui qui consiste à dire
tout être vivant sensible qui né sur
cette planète a le droit. de vivre. Donc
une vache doit pas être tuée enfin en
l'occurrence souvent les vaches. Les
vaches en fait leur vie est plus
compliquée que ça puis d'abord elles
produisent du lait pour nous pendant
font des
pendant quelques années avant de avant
d'être envoyé. Mais les veaux les veaux
c'est quelques mois par exemple. Bon ben
ce veau il doit pas être tué au bout de
quelques mois pour nous ce même s'il est
super bien nourri gambade le cochon même
chose le cochon il a pas être tué au
bout de 6 mois.
La chasse euh
chasse une hérésie aujourd'hui.
Alors euh imagine-toi l'humain qui
produit un peu de pinard dans ses
vignes. Il se lève un matin et il y a un
troupeau de sanglier, une harde de
sanglier qui lui a ruiné Ouais.
son pinard. Euh on fait quoi ? On on
régule,
on discute avec le sanglier, on va boire
un coup,
on on laisse les loups les loups vont
autoréguler les sangliers. On fait quoi
d'abord ? effectivement une grande place
à l'autorégulation, c'està dire que la
nature s'est autorégulée pendant
prédateur quand même. On réintroduit des
prédateurs, on fait quoi ?
Ce sont des questions qu'il faut se
poser effectivement. Recréer des
équilibres que nous avons nous-mêmes euh
l'homme fait partie de nous éliminé.
Est-ce que l'homme l'homme est un loup
pour le sanglier ?
Est-ce que l'homme est un loup pour le
sanglier ?
Non. L'homme est est fait partie de cet
équilibre avec une place à part. C'està
dire que c'est le seul animal sur cette
planète aujourd'hui qui a le pouvoir de
vie et de mort sur tout ce qu'il
entoure. C'est le seul. Ça lui confère
une responsabilité particulière, celle
justement de prendre soin du vivant.
Toi, tu as pas discuté avec le chat de
ma belle- sœur.
Parce qu'il tue des souris, c'est ça ?
Il veut être maître du monde.
Autre question d'internet. Pourquoi
accepter la prédation du loup et pas
celle de l'homme ? Mais parce que nous
ne sommes pas des loups, comme nous ne
sommes pas des souris, comme euh nous ne
sommes pas des éléphants, les
antispécistes ne disent pas tous les
animaux sont égaux en terme d'intérêt,
en terme de capacité. Ils disent tous
les animaux non humains sensibles et les
humains ont les inclus dedans, ont on
ont le droit le même droit à vivre, à
exister, à ne pas souffrir. Voilà.
Ensuite, nous avons tous des
caractéristiques différentes et comme je
viens de le dire, l'homme est non
seulement l'espèce
dominatrice aujourd'hui dominante, mais
en plus c'est l'espèce animale qui a les
caractéristiques cognitives les plus
développées et notamment le sens de la
morale et de l'éthique. La morale et
l'éthique sont présentes également chez
d'autres espèces animales, même chez les
rats par exemple, on a découvert
l'entrée, le sens de la justice ou de
l'injustice, l'empathie. On a découvert
tout ça chez chez des animaux dont les
rats. Bon, mais chez ces chez c'est chez
l'homme que ses caractéristiques sont
les plus développées. Et ça Darwin
l'avait déjà expliqué au 19e siècle dans
un livre qui s'appelle la descendance de
l'homme. Il avait déjà dit que les
qualités morales est ce qui était apparu
en dernier chez les animaux qu'il
appelait lui supérieur. Et il expliquait
ce que que la morale, il parle bien de
morale, que la morale allait se
développer de plus en plus était devenu
aujourd'hui un élément qui permettait
l'évolution de notre espèce.
Question internet, tu as fini ?
Oh non, je pourrais parler un quart
d'heure mais vas-y. Vy.
En tant en tant que militant
antispéciste, puis-je avoir un lombri
compost
de la poudre de verre de terre ?
Bah non.
D'accord. Et à l'ombre compose des verrs
de terre qui s'occupent de faire les
esclaves pour décomposer.
Là, on parle de de de verre de terre
vivant dans la deuxième C'est ça.
Récompost, c'est alors je je c'est c'est
les verres de terre qui Oui, c'est ça.
Est-ce que si ils sont morts mais ça
aucun intérêt. Ils sont pas son dans une
boîte. Ils sont dans une boîte, ils
s'occupent de de recycler les les
déchets. D'accord. Donc des verrs de
terre vivants qui Oui, ça pourquoi pas.
Moi ça me moi ça ne me pose pas de
problème à partir du moment où un verre
de terre n'est pas privé de moi ce qui
m'ennuie c'est comment il est stocké
dans cette boîte et qu'est-ce qui lui
arrive si cette boîte n'est pas vendu et
pendant le le comment il est c'est ça
qui je connais pas du tout ce système
donc je je voudrais pas m'engager l'idée
de se dire on on importe des verrs de
terre dans sa terre pour les faire
travailler à sa terre c'est différent
parce que il est pas vraiment esclave
simplement on le change de territoire
mais on lui donne le même espace qu'il
aurait eu là si si on avait pas bougé
son espace de naissance mais ce qui
m'ennuie dans ce système
Mais je n'en ai pas la certitude. C'est
la possibilité qu'on prenne des verrs de
terre quand il vous compa dans une
petite boîte qu'on met dans un
supermarché qu'on attend. C'est pas ça
j'imagine, c'est pas possible parce que
si on fait ça les ils vont ils vont
crever. Donc en tout cas qu'on déplace
des verrs de terre pour les les mettre
dans un terrain où leur travail va être
utile, ça ne me gêne pas.
Autre question internet. Que pensez-vous
de la viande de synthèse ?
Ça ne me gêne pas. Je sais que c'est
quelque chose qui est euh décrié par les
adversaires des végans qui disent "Mon
dieu, regardez, euh les véganfent un
système euh alimentaire complètement pas
naturel au service des grandes
entreprises qui veulent justement
investir le le territoire de la viande
de synthèse. Moi, je je m'en moque. Je
suis pas sûr que soit très utile parce
que les végan qui s'y connaissent un peu
arrivent très très bien aujourd'hui à se
nourrir sans avoir recours. Forcément,
ça n'existe pas encore, en tout cas,
c'est pas encore commercialisé, c'est
beaucoup trop cher sans sans avoir
recours à ça. Maintenant, si ça peut
aider un certain nombre de personnes qui
sont vraiment aujourd'hui accroch qui
aimeraient arrêter mais voilà et qui ont
trop pris l'habitude de de cette la
viande et qui se sentent rassurés par le
fait d'avoir de la viande dans leur
assiette mais simplement c'est la viande
de synthèse qui n'a pas fait souffrir
d'animal, pourquoi pas ? peut être ça
peut être en tout cas dans une phase de
transition ça peut être un un peu comme
un patch euh un patch pour arrêter de
fumer.
Est-ce que Est-ce que tu as vu le le la
vidéo satirique qui s'appelle la
boucherie éthique ?
Alors on m'a beaucoup parlé mais je j'ai
très honnêtement je l'ai jamais regardé
mais je sais just fait au moins 10
personnes qui m'en parlent.
Autre question d'internet. Est-ce que le
trappeur inuite qui pratique un rituel
pour retirer la flèche de la bête qui
l'a tué et qui rend hommage à l'âme de
cet animal ne respecte pas finalement
plus cette bête dans son animalité que
l'éleveur le plus bio.
Ouais.
La lalie
si dans la mesure où on considère que
l'inuite ce qui est pas plus forcément
vrai aujourd'hui n'aurait pas d'autres
choix pas d'autres solutions pour
continuer lui-même à vivre que d'enlever
une vie. C'est parce que il est il vit
dans un milieu tel que bah son seul
choix est de tuer cet animal.
Et s'il le fait avec respect parce que
c'est lui euh c'est lui qui meurt ou
c'est c'est c'est cet animal. Enfin
effectivement et de toute manière je
peux comprendre ça j'en parlais dans un
de mes hypnothèques qu'à une certaine
époque de notre vie on était obligé de
tuer des animaux comme par exemple pour
tout simplement avoir moins froid pour
prendre la peau pour se la mettre sur
les épaules quand il fait mo- 10°gr dans
certaines régions. Je comprends que les
humains aient eu besoin certain moment
de leur histoire de le faire. Il se
trouve simplement que nous sommes entre
joint dans une phase où nous n'avons
absolument plus besoin de tuer des
animaux pour nous vêtir, pour nous
nourrir et cetera. Est-ce qu'il y a
encore des régions où c'est absolument
obligatoire pour des populations de le
faire ? Je ne le pense pas. Je pense que
même les inuites aujourd'hui, on peut
les alimenter en produits. Véan.
Bah ouais.
Tes chaussures, elles sont en cuir
végétal ?
Ouais, c'est on peut on cite pas la
marque.
Bah, c'est surtout que je la connais
pas. C'est un site allemand. Je peux les
enlever pour regarder ce qui est J'ai
acheté ça sur internet par un site
allemand sur un site allemand végan. Euh
antispéciste versus tradition française.
Comment le faire entrer un minimum dans
la dans les consciences ?
Genre la la tradition gastronomique
française
une bonne un peuf bourguignon,
un poulet homorit
un agneau de 7. La tradition n'a aucun
intérêt.
C'estàd que je suis toujours assez
effaré de d'entendre des gens
aujourd'hui brandir le mot tradition
pour justifier certaines pratiques.
Corriida, tradition. Ben non, en plus
c'est même pas une tradition française
d' Corida, donc c'est complètement faux.
Euh la tradition c'est une habitude
prise par un groupe d'humain à un moment
donné de leur histoire. Beaucoup de
traditions reposent sur des croyances,
sur des méconnaissances aussi. Et ce
n'est pas parce que il y a une pratique
à un moment donné notre histoire qu'on
doit la continuer tout le temps. Ce qui
doit guider nos actions, c'est
simplement le fait de savoir si cette
action est raisonnable ou pas, si elle
est justifiée ou pas. Si on découvre
tout à coup que quelque chose qu'on
avait l'habitude de faire a des
conséquences absolument dramatiques,
néfastes ou immorales, il est logique
d'arrêter. Donc c'est le cas de la
corida. euh la viande, par manger de la
viande, et ben on découvre aujourd'hui
des choses sur les animaux qu'on ne
savait pas avant sur leur intelligence,
leur sensibilité. On découvre
aujourd'hui des qu'on a des possibilités
de se nourrir complètement différentes
et on change la tradition. Vous savez
que euh pendant des euh pendant des des
années en France, par exemple,
traditionnellement pendant la nuit de la
Saint-Jean, on clouait des chats aux
portes, on les brûlait. C'est la
tradition. Bah, on a arrêté. Tiens,
voilà.
Que pensez-vous des mouvements citoyens
et étudiants pour le climat ainsi que
les projets comme l'affaire du siècle ?
Bah,
je ne peux qu'être très enthousiasmé par
tout ça.
Est-ce que la non violence protège les
puissants ?
C'est une excellente question.
Ça les ça les aide en tout cas. Oui,
ça les aide.
C'est c'est on en revient aussi à
quelque chose qu'on a abordé tout à
l'heure sur pourquoi les libéraux
gagnent parce que ce sont des tricheurs.
Vous avez dans une rue un non violent
qui tout à coup se confronte à un type
sur armé ou un type qui sort de son
cours
de de karaté et qui va en découdre.
Bon bah, on a une chance sur deux que
non, pas une chance sur deux, on a 9
chances sur 10 que le type qui sait se
battre et qui a envie de se battre et
ben sorte
sorte de cet échange bénéficiaire. Ou
alors il faut que le nonvolence soit
très très très convaincant,
mais il part en tout cas avec un sacré
désavantage.
Euh plutôt molotof ou cacatof ?
Et ben Kacatof,
que pensez-vous de la montée de la
violence d'État et de la réaction face
aux demandes de l'ONU à la France usage
du LBD, ben c'est plutôt qu'est-ce que
je pense du mépris total des autorités
françaises ou des commentateurs que l'on
sur les chaînes info par rapport au
jugement qu'imit aujourd'hui l'ONU à
notre égard enfin en tout cas à l'égard
de nos dirigeants. C'est-à-dire qu'on
est aujourd'hui vraiment pointé du doigt
comme étant
comme étant en pleine dérive et
je suis heureux qu'il a des instances
internationales qui soient là pour le
signaler. Malheureusement, ça n'aura
aucun effet parce qu'il y a une forme
d'arrogance totale de notre gouvernement
à l'égard de tout ça. J'ai posté une
vidéo qui était d'ailleurs celle de une
relayée par David Dufren il y a de tr
jours sur Twitter. Je voyais un jeune
homme qui qui marchait avec un tambour.
Ça m'a Mais ça m'a ça m'a
c'est pire que révolter.
C'est une action isolée
ça. Non non c'est pas isolé. C'est pas
isolé. C'est pas isolé. C'est il y en a
tous les enfin il y a des des dizaines
et des dizaines et des dizaines de
vidéos de les
vidéos des lunettes par terre. Non
j'ai vu les c'était le même jour.
Donc je termine sur cette histoire de
vidéo euh et et on voit donc un jeune
homme comme ça qui tape sur son tambour
tranquillement dans sa rue pour
manifester. Voilà. Puis des cestes qui
arrivent, qui le prennent violemment,
qui lui cassent son tambour, qui qui le
mettent à terre mais comme c'était un
délinquant, comme s'il venait d'
il les avait provoqué avec un tambour,
faut pas déconner.
Ouais, mais là je me suis dit et j'ai
écrit "Arrêtons de arrêtons de nous
gargariser avec
Rousseau et Hugo mais il y a quelque
chose, je blague". Enfin, ça c'est
quelque chose ça me ça me retourne
vraiment mais quand je dis que ça me
retourne, ça me déprime au plus haut
point. C'est-à-dire qu'on est censé être
le pays de Hugo. On est les gens, on
brandito. Regardez. Alors, c'est super.
Alors, les misérables, c'est joué à
Broadway, c'est génial. On est fier de
ça. Mais mais en fait, on les supporte
plus les Gavroches aujourd'hui. On n'en
veut pas dans notre pays. Et le discours
de Hugo aujourd'hui, plus personne n'en
veut en réalité, parmi ceux qui nous
dirigent.
Une question. Avez-vous vu le débat de
Derugie pour répondre aux plaintes de
l'affaire du siècle ? Que pensez-vous
des propositions gouvernementales sur le
climat et la consommation de viande en
particulier ?
À suivre tout de suite, si la non
violence prend parfois des limites,
quand est-ce que la violence s'impose ?
H
vous parlez de décisions raisonnables.
Pour qu'elle alors pour qu'elles soit
raisonnable, ne faut-il pas qu'elle soit
partagée par le plus grand nombre ?
Non, pour qu'elle soit raisonnable, elle
doit pas être partagée par le plus grand
nombre parce que la raison en fait,
c'est ce qu'on essaie de d'éterrer,
c'est ce qu'on essaie de
de mettre au jour, mais euh parfois on
on passe à côté de la raison pendant des
siècles.
Euh
la manière dont on a perçu par exemple
euh la planète Terre dans le système
solaire ou voilà jusqu'à Copernic, on
pensait que que que c'est le le c'était
la terre, le centre du monde et que et
que le soleil tournait autour de la
terre. Et donc on était à côté de la
raison. Bon euh donc on peut être très
très raisonnable en en minorité. En
revanche, je dis que l'idéal serait de
convaincre le plus grand monde possible
de suivre une voie raisonnable. Je ne
sais pas si c'est facilement réalisable.
On on y est parvenu. On peut quand même
être assez optimiste lorsqu'on regarde
l'histoire de nos sociétés depuis de
millénaires. On voit quand même que sur
de très nombreux sujets, nous avons
progressé. Nous avons, comme j'aime à
dire augmenté nos sphères de
considération morale. Nous l'avons
étendu à quasiment tous les individus
alors que initialement
beaucoup des individus étaient exclus
cette sphère de considération morale à
savoir les femmes, les homosexuels, les
les les personnes de couleur, les
personnes de certaines religions et
cetera et cetera. Donc on peut
considérer qu'avec le temps, avec la
discussion, on arrive quand même à aller
vers un certain progrès moral.
Est-ce que tu as des sujets à aborder
qu'on a pas abordé ? plein. Euh, on est
là pour 3 jours.
Euh euh, on arrive à la fin de de notre
émission. Euh euh
on a fait combien de temps ?
Aucune idée. Et on arrive à la fin de
notre émission. Alors,
ils s'en fout de mes questions.
Ouais.
Le le
Non, parce que j'ai j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il y avait pas de durée vraiment. Euh
ouais, mais comme tu es arrivé avec tr
quart d'heure de une demi-heure en
retard, c'est compliqué. Et
non mais ça n'a pas eu d'influence sur
la durée de notre interview,
rassure-moi.
Non, ça
donc c'était juste un petit tacle de fin
pour dire que je suis arrivé avec 3
minutes de retard.
Combien tu as dit combien tu as dit ?
30 minutes de retard.
Bon, je déteste ça.
On sait pas en plus voilà, on a fait une
interview normalement mais
le donc 1h et dem c'est pas mal parce
que il paraît que c'est vrai que quand
tu aimes pas, tu vires au bout d'un
quart d'heure, 20 minutes.
Non, c'est pas quand j'aime pas, c'est
quand tu arrives en retard et que tu
joues ta diva, tu dégages.
Et et j'ai joué ma diva.
Non non non. Ben 1hure et ça va. Tu veux
rester une demi-heure de plus ?
Non pas du tout. Je trouve que c'était
très bien justement. J'allais te dire
c'est super, on a vachement parlé.
Ouais. Bah arrête de me déconcentrer là
en fait c'est ça. Il aime pas
déstabilisé. C'est c euh la dernière
question qui n'est pas une question,
c'est laisser un conseil pour les jeunes
générations et euh donc si tu as un
conseil à laisser une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose d'impérissable. Et
moi, je vais te poser une question juste
juste pour pour moi. Est-ce que tu
connais le poème Le Reniement de
Saint-Pierre qui se termine par
Certes, je sortirai quant à moi
satisfait d'un monde où l'action n'est
pas la sœur du rêve. Puisse
puisse-je user du glève et périr par le
glève. Saint-Pierre a renié Jésus, il a
bien fait.
Tu peux envoyer ton conseil pour les
jeunes générations.
Euh c'est compliqué. J'aime pour donner
des conseils. Non, c'est vrai, c'est
très Non, non, la seule la seule chose
c'est pas un conseil et je ne peux déjà
je passe mon temps à me demander si je
fais bien. Alors, aller donner un
conseil aux autres. Quand j'écris des
livres, j'expose toujours une vision des
choses qui est la mienne en me demandant
si je peux la partager avec d'autres.
J'ai pas la prétention de penser
enfin si quand j'en parle, je dois
forcément avoir un souci d'universalité,
surtout ce que je parle d'éthique, des
droits des animaux.
Mais de là à donner des conseils, non ?
Le seul conseil que ce que j'aimerais
c'est que chacun vraiment mette le mot
éthique au cœur de chacune de ces
décisions.
Ça change tout. S'il y a un conseil,
c'est de savoir dire non. C'est-à-dire
qu'en gros, on je pense qu'on n'est pas
du tout éduqué dans le bon sens. On nous
apprend à être poli. C'est bien la
politesse. J'ai déploré en début
d'interview que certains ont manqué même
pour exprimer leur désaccord. Vous
apprend être soumis. Oui, bien sûr.
L'école, c'est l'école de la soumission,
celle à laquelle vont nos enfants
aujourd'hui. Cette école commence pas à
la maternelle parce qu'on a là encore
des méthodes pédagogiques encore de
développement personnel, mais dès le
collège, ça devient l'école de la
soumission. On nous apprend une forme de
respect qui, j'adore le respect, tu as
compris dans les rapports humains. En
revanche, je crois que on doit tous être
élevés avec la capacité à contredire, à
mettre en question ce qu'on nous dit
comme une vérité. On doit être tous
habitués, éduqués à interroger cette
vérité qu'on nous présente comme telle.
Savoir dire non. Je pense que notre
liberté, elle est là aujourd'hui dans un
univers où une société où nos libertés
sont de plus en plus restreintes. Il
nous reste une petite marge, c'est celle
qui consiste à dire "Je refuse cela". Et
je crois que la vie se fait beaucoup
plus par refus que par acceptation.
Caron, merci.
Merci à vous pour votre accueil.
[Musique]